AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO THE
WIND CITY DITION OF THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE WE WELCOME EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU BEFORE WE GET
INTO THIS AFTERNOON'S HEARING
WE'D LIKE TO BE TO COVER SOME
HOUSEKEEPING IN MAKING SURE.
THAT ALL OF US ARE ON THE SAME
PAGE AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN
TODAY'S HEARING. WOULD LIKE TO
BE TO MAKE NOTE THAT ALL
MEMBERS ALL NAY OF THE WE BE
PRESENT IN THE HEARING ROOM
TODAY OR NOT BE ANY MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. NOW
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT BILLS FOR
THE DAY THEY'RE GONNA BE SIX
BILLS THAT WILL BE SLATED FOR
IN PERSON HEARING TEN FOR
CONSENT WE'RE GONNA BE ADDING
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE WE'RE ADDING
ITEM NUMBER TWO. AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE A SEPTEMBER QUIRK
YOUR ACTION ITEMS THIS
AFTERNOON. PETER HERTZBERG TAKE
MOMENT SAY THANK YOU TO SEE
HURTS. HE'S GOING TO BE
pPRESENTING FOR DIFFERENT
ASSEMBLY MILLS I'D LIKE TO LIST
THEM OUT TODAY. WILL BE WORKING
TWO OF US IN NUMBER BURKE
SPILLS. ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH
IS FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN. HE
ALSO BE PRESENTING ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN.
HE'S GONNA BE PRESENTING THEN
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY ONE AS A MEMBER WICKS AND
THEN HE WILL BE PRESENTING OUR
NEW NUMBER SIX WHICH USED TO BE
NUMBER TWELVE ON OUR AGENDA AND
THAT IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLING OVER IT
WILL BE PRESENTING THEIR BILLS
HERE IN COMMITTEE. I NOW WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO COVER OUR
PARTICIPATION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU. WE'RE
GONNA WELCOME COMMENTS THREE
DIFFERENT WAYS IN TODAY'S
HEARING. THE FIRST IS THROUGH
OUR LIVE LINE THROUGH THE
TELEPHONE WE'RE GONNA WELCOME
YOUR PARTICIPATION. IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSED TO THE BILL TO THE
FOLLOWING NUMBER. CALL US EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. THAT NUMBER IS
NOW ON YOUR SCREEN YOU'RE GOING
TO DIAL THE CODE. FIVE EIGHT
TWO SIX FIVE NINE EIGHT WE
WELCOME YOUR COMMENTS VIA
TELEPHONE. YOU'RE ALSO WELCOME
TO BETTER PROVIDE TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE. YOU CAN ALSO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY HERE IN THE CAPITAL
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. AGAIN WE
ASK FOR A LITTLE PATIENCE TODAY
WE'RE GONNA GO SLOW BUT STEADY.
WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE THAT ALL
VOICES ARE HEARD. AND FINALLY I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE TO OUR VICE
CHAIR. VICE CHAIR MORE LOCK.
THE VICE CHAIR HAS BEEN MORE
THAN CONSIDERED OF HIS TIME
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE ON THE
SAME PAGE MOVING INTO THIS
TRUNCATED BILL HEARING SEASON.
AND I WANTED KNOWLEDGE OF I
SHARE I CANNOT SAY THANK YOU
ENOUGH MISTER MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP WE'RE VERY VERY
GRATEFUL TO WORK WITH YOU EACH
AND EVERY DAY. ALSO LIKE. THE
GOVERNOR I NEED TO HAVE. UNDER
CONDITIONS AND AT TIMES QUITE
STRESSFUL. IN ESPECIALLY WHEN A
INTRODUCED STAFF DIRECTOR
CONGER NOW. AND SAY THANK YOU
MISTER NOW FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK. SPEAKING OF MISTER NOW
HE'S NOT GOING TO CALL THE ROLL
AND WE'RE GONNA SELL SHOULD
CORNER MR NOW. UNDER MCGUIRE.
CHOIR HERE ARE PRESENT SENATE
MORLOCK. MORLOCK PRESENT
SENATOR BELL. BELL PRESENT
SENATOR HERTZBERG HERE WHICH
BURKE PRESENT. CENTER HURTADO.
PRESENT RICARDO PRESENT SENATOR
NIELSEN HERE NIELSEN PRESENT
SENATOR WINNER. YOUR LOCAL
ALRIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
COMMITTEE A QUORUM HAS OPENED
ESTABLISH A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED WE'RE GOING TO KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN UNTIL- IS SENATOR
WIENER ARISE. THE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE'RE NOW GOING TO
START WITH OUR FOR ASSEMBLY
BILLS THAT THE GOOD SENATOR OUR
MAJORITY LEADER SENATOR
HERTZBERG WILL BE PRESENTING.
AT MR HERTZBERG WOULD IT BE
ALRIGHT IF WE PRESENT A SUMMER
BURKE'S TWO BILLS FIRST WOULD
BE ALRIGHT WITH YOU SIR
ABSOLUTELY NO PROBLEM ALL RIGHT
ITEM NUMBER TWO LET'S START OUT
WITH FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN THEN
WE'LL GO TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
AB TWENTY TWO FORTY AND MISS
MAJORITY LEADER THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR ORK ON THIS THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR. THANK YOU
MISTER MINISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS. AND YOU KNOW I GOT
A LOT OF REGARD FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND- I THINK THIS
IS- I'M KILEY HONORED TO BE
PRESENTING FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BILLS. AS ALL OF US DURING
THESE EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGING
TIME TRY TO WORK TOGETHER A
COMEDY EACH OTHER. IN THE MOST
GRACIOUS AND RESPECTFUL MANNER.
AND SO WITH THAT I WILL START
WITH OF THE BILLS AND I HAVE A
ALSO ANOTHER BILL THAT'S ON
CONSENT JUST IN CASE BUT FILED
NUMBER TWO. AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. ALL THESE MEASURES IN
ONE FORM OR ANOTHER DEAL WITH
THE EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGES
WERE FACING WITH THE- GLOBAL
PANDEMIC. THIS OF COURSE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. HAS GIVEN
THESE- ALONE SEIZE PPP LOANS
AND SO WHAT WE'RE SEEKING TO
DO. WHAT A SERVER BURKE CHAIR
OF THE RIBBON TAX COMMITTEE IS
SEEKING TO DO WAS TO CONFORM
ARE FOR CALIFORNIA STATE LAW.
THE FEDERAL LAW TO ENSURE THAT
THE PAYCHECK PROTECTION LOANS.
AUTHORIZED BY THE CHARACTERS
ACT. AS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S DONE. ARE NOT
TAXABLE THE ANALYSIS ON THIS
MEASURES GOOD. AND ANSWERS ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS PEOPLE
HAVE BUT THE INTEREST OF TIME.
I THINK THAT THAT. PRESENTS THE
CASE. FOR TAX. CAL TAX COME IN
BUT IN SOME. ON ITS CITY.
MEASURE I THANK GOD DEALING
WITH THE CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE
FACING PARTICULARLY ALL THE
BUSINESSES ARE GETTING. THESE
KINDS OF LOANS ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE I ASK
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL AGAIN COMMONSENSE
APPROACH IN AND GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT YOUR WOMAN. FOR
ALL OF OUR WORK ON THIS LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN WHAT WE'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO DO IS WE'D LIKE TO
START OUT WITH HERE- OUR
WITNESSES AND OUR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. WE'RE GONNA START
OUT FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE HAVE ONE
INDIVIDUAL WHO THE LEAD SUPPORT
WHICH YES HIS NAME IS JASON
FOX. CALIFORNIA THIS IDEA P.
A.'S MISTER FOX TO MAKE SURE
YOU'RE ON THE ON THE LINE
AFTERNOON SIR YOU COMMITTEE YOU
HAVE THREE. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA KEEP MOVIN AS- MISTER FOX
HAS NOT YET CALLED IN. LADIES
IN GERMAN WE'RE NOT GOING TO
CONTINUE WITH THOSE IN SUPPORT
IT MISTER FOX CALLS IN HERE
MOMENTARILY. JOINT ALL RIGHT A
META MODERATOR THAT SAID CHECK
INTO IS MISTER FOX ON THE LINE
MATTER MODERATOR. ONE MOMENT
WHILE ON. MISTER FOX IS NOW ON
THE LINE AND HIS MIND IS OPEN
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER FOX
URINE COMMITTEE THIS IS AT
CENTER MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES THE FLOOR IS YOURS IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. A GOOD ACTORS AREN'T
BUDGET BOXES THE COPPER IDEA
CERTIFIED PUBLIC ACCOUNTANT IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN SEVEN
SEVEN. SENATOR THEN VOTED- OUR
MEMBERS WOULD BEEN WORKING WITH
TALENT FOR THE FED TO ADVISE.
THE IMPACT OF THE COVER A TEAM
CRIED. THX ATTENTION PROGRAM
IT'S BEEN CERTAINLY ONE OF THE
VEHICLE WHO'S BEEN WORKING WITH
OUR MEMBERS AND- TO THE
IMPORTANT CLEAN THAT MEASURE
THE PPP ALONE FOR THE CARE THEY
ARE- THEY TO CLEAR THAT. PEOPLE
LOVE THE TAXABLE BUT-
CALIFORNIA NOT CONFORM TO THIS
UNTIL EIGHTY FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN WHAT. NEARLY CONFORM TO
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT- MEASURE
LOOKING AT WHAT A LOT OF
CONFUSION AND POSSIBLY-
UNEXPECTED- TAX LIABILITIES OR
TAX PAYERS- IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY EPICURE SO. THANK YOU
ARE JUST PART OF AB FIFTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH VERY
GRATEFUL MISTER FOX INTO
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS LADIES
IN GERMAN WE'RE GOING TO STICK
WITH THE ART TELEPHONE
WITNESSES WE'RE GONNA TURN OVER
TO THE MODERATOR MATTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE A TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN WE'RE LOOKING FOR FOLKS
ON OUR LIVE LINE WHEN YOU SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN MATTER MODERATOR.
ABSOLUTELY AND THANK YOU END OF
THE VISION OF YOU WHO WISH TO
COMMENT IN FAVOR OF AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
FAVOR OF AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND OUR FIRST
COMMENT COMES FROM LINE THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
AFTERNOON. HI THIS IS DARIA
MCGREW ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
VERY GRATEFUL TO THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MADAME MODERATOR
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AT NINE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DUSTIN WHETHER BE THE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD TO
HEAR YOUR VOICE WE APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS. AT A MODERATOR
LET'S CHECK IN TO SEE WHO OUR
NEXT CALLER IS PLEASE. AT NINE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON.
BUT NOT A BIG DEAL BILL HELP
WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATIONAND WE'RE CALLING
IN SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS MADAME
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
SB JUST ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
GATHER THE MY NUMBERS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH LAYS INJURED ON THE
COMMITTEE THE MODERATOR IS NOT
GONNA BE QUEUING UP ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT AT A MODERATOR WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A LOOK AT OUR QUEUE
HOW MANY FOLKS ARE CUED UP IN
SUPPORT OF. FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. NINE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON A GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
PRESSING YOUNG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT THIS YOUNG THANK YOU
SO MUCH COULD BE HERE VOICE
MATTER MODERATOR HOW MANY OTHER
FOLKS ARE CUED UP ON OUR LIVE
LINE. NO ONE ELSE IN Q. IN.
COMMENTING IN FAVOR OF AB.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAME
MODERATOR DO YOU MIND DOING IT
ONE LAST CALL ONE LAST CALL FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT.
ABSOLUTELY IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN FAVOR OF AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN. ONE AND THEN
ZERO. MINIMUM WRITER ANYONE
ELSE CUED UP FOR SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN. WE HAVE
NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MASON CHEN ON THE COMMITTEE
WERE NOW GOING TO BE GOING TO
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE
TO MY LEFT HEARING SEEN NO ONE
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE GOING TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. THERE IS NO
LOVE NO LOVE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY- AND THERE IS NO ONE
READY TO SPEAK IN THAT ROOM
WE'RE NOT GONNA BRING IT BACK
WE'RE GONNA START THIS OVER
AGAIN WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO TO
THE MODERATOR IN ASK OUR
MODERATOR TO BE AND SEE IF SHE
COULD PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE
WHO MAY BE OPPOSED AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN. OPPOSED TO AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN MATTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
OUR CALL CAN YOU PLEASE Q. OUR
CALLERS OUT. THANK YOU. HE WAS
TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION. AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN.
OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO ONE IN THE OPPOSITION Q.
THANK YOU SO MUCH KNOWN AS IN
THE OPPOSITION Q. WE'RE GONNA
BE GOING TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSE HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OF THREE HEARING SEEN NO ONE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. THERE'S NO ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WHO ARE
OPPOSED TO AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING
FOR VICE CHAIR TO BE ABLE TO
OPEN COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE.
AND WILL TURN IT BACK OVER TO
THE MAJORITY LEADER AS WELL TO
BE OUR FIELD ANY QUESTIONS.
MISTER VICE CHAIR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR WITH
THE MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY. THE
I STE- GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE LAST
CALL. KERN SEEN. MR MAJORITY
LEADER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY WOMAN
BURKE. SPECTRALLY ASKED FOR AND
I WROTE THANK YOU SO MUCH THE
MOTION MADE BY VICE CHAIR
MORLOCK IS A DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS THE SERVER NOW
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BETTER MCGUIRE BY WATER HI
SENATOR MORLOCK BY WILL WALK BY
SENATOR BILL. I FELT I SENATOR
HERTZBERG BY. SENATOR HURT AUTO
HI RICARDO SENATOR NIELSEN AYE
AYE NIELSEN AYE SENATOR WIENER.
THAT CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX
ZERO VOTE MEMBERS A COMMITTEE
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THIS ROLE
OPEN TO ALLOW CENTER WIENER TO
BE ABLE TO ADD ON LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WERE NOW
GIVE ME MOVING ON TO- AB TWENTY
TWO FORTY SEVEN THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER FOUR ON OUR AGENDA AB
TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN
PRESENTED BY YOU GUESSED IT THE
MAJORITY LEADER SENATOR
HERTZBERG. IT'S HERTZBERG THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APOLOGIZE AFTER MOVE MY
MASTER BELOW IS A FOX OF MY
GLASSES. TO JUST FOR A MOMENT.
THIS IS A MEASURE SPONSORED BY
OUR OWN CALIFORNIA FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD TO CORRECT AND MAKE A
TAXPAYER FRIENDLY CORRECTION TO
THE LAW. RECENTLY OUR FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD LEARNED THAT THE
INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICE OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS STOPPED
ISSUING OR RENEWING INDIVIDUAL
TAXPAYER IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS
FOR NON RESIDENT DEPENDENTS
LIVING IN CANADA AND MEXICO
THIS IS PRESENT PREVENTED
CERTAIN OF OUR CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS FROM CLAIMING THE
EXISTENT DEPENDENT EXEMPTION
CREDIT FOR THE OTHERWISE
QUALIFYING NON RESIDENT.
DEPENDENCE THIS IS BECAUSE
CURRENT STATE LAW BUT MEMBERS
REQUIRES A TAX RETURN TO
INCLUDE EITHER SO SCREWED EMBER
OR AND A NIGHT T. R. YEAH AND
FOR EACH DEPENDENT FOR THE
CREDIT ALLOWED THIS MEASURE.
WOULD GIVE THE TAXPAYER THE
OPTION OF PROVIDING ALTERNATIVE
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION FOR
PURPOSES OF CLAIMING THE
DEPENDENT EXEMPTION ALLOWED
UNDER OUR LAW AGAIN SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS THE SPONSOR-
FROM THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
THANK YOU MEMBERS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE MAJORITY LEADER
LAYS IN GERMAN WE DO HAVE ONE
LEAD WITNESS HER NAME IS
ANNETTE CURRENCY SHE'S FROM THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD WE'RE GONNA
CHECK IN WITH OUR MODERATOR
MADAME MODERATOR TO WITNESS
CLEANS THE FROM THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD PREPARED TO. B. R.
LEAD WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN MATTER
MODERATOR THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
YES AND THAT COUNTRY IT IS
AVAILABLE AND THE HER LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON. OKAY WELL
NOT. AFTER ALL CHAIRED BY
CARING COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
HERTZBERG FOR PROVIDING
AFFORDABLE MY NAME IS AN
ACTIVITY IN ON THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE FRANCHISE CAPS
FOR HIS ON ON AN ONGOING BASIS
SB IDENTIFY POSSIBLE IDEAS FOR
THE PUBLIC BACKING A PASTA
MINISTRATION INCLUDING THE ONE
PRESENTED BEFORE YOU TODAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. TO CONSULTANT OF
IBM. AN ADVENTURE AND CAL. HAS
TO GET EXEMPTION CREDIT AND
THEY'RE ALLOWED BUT DEPENDING
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER. AND
INDIVIDUALS IDENTIFICATION
NUMBER ALSO KNOWN AS I CAN.
STARTING IN THE TAX YEAR TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN A DEPENDENT
TAXPAYERS IDENTIFICATION
NUMBER. STARTED HAVE TO BE
PROVIDED ON STATE HAVE TO TURN
IN THAT THIS REQUIREMENT WAS
PUT IN PLACE THREE. RESPONSE OF
LEGISLATION TO ENSURE THAT THE
DEPENDENT EXEMPTION CREDIT
CLAIMED ONLY ONCE FOR EACH
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER. FIND OUT
THE ALSO MENTION IDEA TO CHANGE
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL SOME
TAXPAYERS MAY NO LONGER BE ABLE
TO CHANGE I CAN. FOR THEIR
DEPENDENTS WHO ARE NOT
PHYSICALLY PRESENT IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WAS AYE IN
CANADA OR MEXICO. SO WHAT THIS
MEANS IS TAXPAYERS WHO ARE%
UNABLE TO FOURTEEN AYE TEMPLE
TO HELP ME. IDENTIFICATION
COMPONENT PUT IN PLACE A FEW
YEARS AGO. I JUST WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO CLARIFY THAT THE
PUBLIC WOULD NOT EXTEND. FAN
ANY ELIGIBILITY BEYOND WHAT IS
CURRENTLY EXISTING WHEN NEARLY
ALLOW THE MECHANISM TO PREVENT
SMILE AT THE CLINIC ADVENTURE
ALL. FOR THOSE WHO OTHERWISE
QUALIFIED. ACOSTA REQUIRED.
PART FOR THE CALL. BY THE
CHANGE FROM AND AWAY TO A GAS
TO THAT AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
ON THE FACT THAT IRAQ MAY KNOW
BE ISSUING I CAN ON ON THEM.
BUT CONSERVING I DON'T. OF ONE.
COMPONENT THAT IS VELOCITY BY.
IN ORDER FOR CHANGE TO BE WILL
BE. TO THE NINETY CREDIT BUT
OTHER QUALIFIED. CHAPTER THREE
THE COST AND THE CHAIN WOULD BE
AND SIGNIFICANT ONE OF.
ESPECIALLY THANK YOU FOR TIME
CONSIDERATION. IT'S GOING TO
THINK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
CONTAINS THE LEGISLATIVE DRY
FROM THE RANCHISE TAX BOARD
PLAYS IN GERMAN COMMITTEE WE'RE
NOW GOING TO BE ASKING OUR
MODERATOR TO BE TO QUEUE UP ALL
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT ALL
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWO FOUR. GONNA GO TO.
TELEPHONE LINES NOW. WATER
MODERN MADAME MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE QUEUE UP ALL THOSE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO
FORTY SEVEN. THANK YOU AND IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN FAVOR OF
AB TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COME IN
FAVOR OF AB TWENTY TWO FORTY
SEVEN PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND OUR FIRST MINE IS MINE
FORTY THREE. PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS THIS IS MICHELLE GAYLE
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO FOUR
SEVEN THANK YOU MICHELLE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO CALL AND WE'RE GRATEFUL META
MODERATOR THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE NO I
MENTIONED Q. BETTER MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE DO A LAST CALL
FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU. AND THOSE WHO WISH TO
COMMENT IN FAVOR OF AB TWENTY
TWO FORTY SEVEN PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
FAVOR OF AB TWENTY TWO FORTY
SEVEN. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT. AS JOHN AT A MODERATOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE LOVE
WORKING WITH YOU WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE KEEPING WITH THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWO FORTY SEVEN. GO TO OUR-
PICK ANY HERE IN THE ROOM YEAH.
LARGE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
WANT TO COMMENT ON THIS. AND
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING OVER
TO FORTY. IT'S A SICK. THIS IS
THE LAW IS ROOM IN THE CAPITOL
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. I KNOW ONE
IS THERE- READY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO FORTY
SEVEN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WE'RE NOW GOING TO OPEN UP OUR
PHONE LINES. CHECKING FOR THOSE
WHO MAY BE OPPOSE. OPPOSED IT
AB TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN. NOT
A MARTYR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP THOSE. OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY
TWO FORTY SEVEN. NEW THANK YOU
AND- WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY TWO
FORTY SEVEN PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION. PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR AB TWENTY TWO FORTY
SEVEN. WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN
Q. THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER
MODERATOR APPRECIATED AGAIN ASK
YOU TO DO A LAST CALL A LAST
CALL FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
HAVE NO COMMENT IN HERE THANK
YOU SO MUCH MATTER MODERATOR
VERY YEAH REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK WE'RE NOT GONNA CHECK
TO ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR THIS BILL IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE. WE SEE
NO ONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR HAVING TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY- LOOKING IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY NO ONE WANTS TO SPEAK IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO TURN BACK TO THE
MAJORITY LEADER. AS WELL AS A
MIDI COMMITTED WITH QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. VICE CHAIR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR. HE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR OF. A JUST A-
QUICK QUESTIONS AS SOMEONE WHO
PREPARE TAX RETURNS FOR A
COUPLE DECADES ALMOST AND- IS
ALSO AN IMMIGRANT I'M JUST TRY
I'VE NEVER HAD THIS. COME UP IN
IN MY EXPERIENCE. FIVE TWO
QUESTIONS WHY DID THE IRS STOP.
RENEWING THE- I. T. I. N. AND
COULD YOU JUST GIVE ME AN
EXAMPLE OF WHERE THIS WOULD
OCCUR I WOULD I WOULD WE WANTED.
IN A SENSE ALLOW FOR A
DEPENDENCY EXEMPTION FOR
SOMEONE THAT DOES NOT RESIDE
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WELL FIRST OF ALL IN ALL TURN
THE FIRST PART OF YOUR UESTION
OVER TO THE EXPERT FROM THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD THAT ARE ON
THE LINE PRESUMABLY STILL.
EXPIRES LIVING IN CANADA AND
MEXICO ARE READY ENTITLED TO
THIS CREDIT BY VIRTUE OF THE
FEDERAL DEFINITION OF THE WORD
DEPENDENT. THIS BILL AT ALL
THIS BILL DOES IS TO GIVE THE
CURRENTLY QUALIFY TAXPAYER A
METHOD. FOR MEETING THEIR TAX
ID OBLIGATIONS THAT GIVES THE
IRS. THIS INFORMATION WHICH IS
NO LONGER ACCEPTING I. T. I.
ENDS. I CAN'T ANSWER THE REASON
FOR THE PUBLIC POLICY CHANGE
THE INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICE.
AND LOOK FOR GUIDANCE FROM THE
OF TOUCH TOUCH BOARD THE-
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE LINE HAS
THINK MISTER HURTS FOR THANK
YOU AND VICE CHAIR. WE'RE GONNA
TURN IT OVER TO OUR MODERATOR
META MODERATOR. WE STILL THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR MISS CAN
SEE ON THE LINE FROM THE FRENCH
ARE. EXPLORED WE DO AND HER
LINUS OF OUR I EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN MISS CAN SEE
I'M GONNA TURN THE FLOOR OVER
AT MADAME LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
TO OUR VICE CHAIR HE HAS A
QUESTION FOR YOU AND IF TO BE
MISTER VICE CHAIR. M. M. IS IN
THE JUST YOU JUST. ON WHAT WHY
THE CHANGE IN THE IRIS POLICY
OF. IN DOING THESE PARTICULAR
IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS. SO WHAT
HAPPENED THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION AT WHAT HAPPENED AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL WAS THERE FOR
CAST YOUR AFTER TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AND BEFORE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. ARE THEY
REDUCE THE PERSONAL EXEMPTION
CREDIT TWO ZERO SO FOR THOSE
HAVE THEIR THAT NO LONGER HAD A
TAX RETURN FOR AND I CAN THERE
WERE NO LONGER- RENEWING THEIR
OR ISSUING. SO AND MY IS THAT
ARE AND I WE COULD VERIFY THAT
CAN I MORE INFORMATION TO THE
COMMITTEE WOULD BE HAPPY TO BUT
HARDLY ANY OF THAT WOULD.
HAPPENED FLAWED BY DEAL BECAUSE
OF SOME OF THOSE I CAN SO
LIMITING TO THE OPPOSITE WHAT
MADE YOU DECIDE TO HELP WITH
THAT BUT AGAIN HAPPY TO PROVIDE
MORE INFORMATION. AND THEN AB
FOR YOUR OTHER. I THINK YOU
WERE LOOKING FOR PERHAPS THE
SCENARIO THAT. MIGHT COME UP
AND I'M HAPPY BUT I DOUBT IF
YOU WOULD LIKE. THESE OKAY SO
FOR EXAMPLE YOU HAVE- COUPLE
CHAPTERS IN CALIFORNIA AND EACH
OF THEM HAS- A RELATIVE AND
CANADA OR MEXICO THAT THEY ARE
ANOTHER WHY COLLEGE BY
DEPENDANT DEPENDENT THERE
MEETING ALL OF THE CAST AND- SO
THEY WOULD NORMALLY QUALIFY AND
MAY WE WOULD ASK FOR THEIR
INFORMATION. I CAN'T GET FIRED
AND SOMETIMES BECAUSE EITHER
MAYBE THERE MORNING UP TO YEAR
WHETHER OR NOT BEING AS OR
PERHAPS THEY THEY HAVE EXPIRED
IN A LONG HAVE TAXI OR THEY
BEEN A PATH TERMINAL THREE. CAN
YOU MAKE A FEW PEOPLE LIVING
THIRTY OTHER WHO ALL HAVE
DEPENDENTS THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
BE HAVE FOR THE FRY THAT THEY.
DO YOU I DO THAT AGAIN. AND FOR
CALIFORNIA. CAN MEET OUR
REQUIRED SO BY PROVIDING THE
ALTERNATIVE METHOD WHAT HOPING
THAT BOTH OF THOSE AT. WILL BE
ABLE MAINTAIN THEIR CREDIT. AND
WE WILL BE ASKING HIM FOR. TO
CALLED. TO PROVIDE THAT I'LL
TURN I KIND OF. WITH IN A
DIFFERENT WAY. AND YELL WHAT DO
WE DO THAT VERY. TO WHAT THEY
WERE. IN ORDER TO OBTAIN A I
CAN. YOU KNOW THAT MAYBE THAT
WE CONSIDER WELL AND WITH THE
BUDGET. CAR THAT HALF OF THE
SUPPORT OF THE- WAS. WAS MADE
BY THE INDIVIDUAL AND FILE THE
FILING AND IN CALIFORNIA. SHOW
ME WE- DAY WHEN. ATTENTION THEY
HAVE THEIR CLEAN DENIED IF THEY
CLAIM IT AND DIDN'T HAVE
ACCORDING INFORMATION CALL. IF
WE ARE IF THEY FELT THAT THIS
WALKING INTO PLAY THEY THOUGHT
THEY WOULD BE ENTITLED TO THAT
CREDIT THAN THEY WOULD PROVIDE
YOU. THAT WE WOULD IN STOCK.
FOR THAT PARTICULAR ITEM BE
CLEAN SO THEY WOULD STILL BE
ABLE MEET THAT REQUIRE. YES
THEY MAY FILE IT AND BECAUSE
ALLOWED. BY BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE THAT I DON'T OF CURRENTLY
LOOKS LIKE THERE'S ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT TO BILL ALL.
CONCLUDE MICHAEL THANK YOU
MISTER. THANK YOU SO MUCH
RESERVE CHAIR LACING CHEN
COMMITTEE WHERE AT LOW FOR.
COMMENTS OR MOTION QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR FROM COMMITTEE. OF
WE A MOTION BY CENTER TOM AMONG
BY SEN TITLE ANY ADDITIONAL OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTING A AT
THIS. TENER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. RESPECTFUL ASK FOR A
VOTE AND OF WILL BURKE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH OF THE HAVE A TERM
BURKE THANK YOU FOR MUCH SENATE
HERTZBERG PITCHING HERE TO YOU
HAVE TO MORE BILLS AGO. THIS
MOTION IS IT TOO PASS
APPROPRIATE SOME WAS MADE SPICE
HER TIE. MR NOW OKAY YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR MCGUIRE
HI WATER I SENATOR MORE WALK.
SENATOR BELL. BELL HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG BY RICH HI SENATOR.
HI RICARDO HI SENATOR NIELSEN.
SENATOR WIENER. FIVE ZERO
PLEASE GERMAN AND THAT IS A
FIVE IS VOTE FIVE EIGHT ZERO
FINAL FOR CLOSING THE ROLE THE
BILL HAS PASSED THANK YOU SO
MUCH LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
COMMITTEE. WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER THREE
ON OUR AGENDA THIS IS AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS WE WANT TO
WISH THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
CONGRATULATIONS SHE JUST HAD
ANOTHER BABY- THIS PAST WEEKEND
SO FANTASTIC NEWS SO PRETENDING
HERE FOR THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
IT'S GONNA BE SENATOR HERTZBERG
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR WE KNOW
IF IT'S A BOY OR A GIRL. I
DON'T KNOW DO WE KNOW I DO NOT
REMEMBER A GRADUAL AT THAT
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA TEACH
TWITTER I'M SURE ON THERE BUT
AS FAR RIGHT SO FIRST IN A IN
PRESENT AND BE OF US MEMBER A
FOR ONE I WANT TO IN THAT THESE
MEMBER OFFICE. HAS EXCEL THE
COULD AMEND TO THIS WITH THE
PARKING WITH OF AB FIFTY ONE
WITH THOSE IN CENTER WIENER AS.
EIGHT NINE NINE AND WITH THIS
SAID HOW PACKAGE ARMS OF THE
CLEAR SO WHAT THIS DOES IT AND
WE FACE THIS HOW FOR SO WITH
SENATOR WE- EIGHT NINE NINE
IT'LL OF THE HOUSING THE.
LEGISLATION XIN. ALL WHY. TO
PUT A PART SPACE NOT
REPLACEMENT ON THE- RULER USE
PART SPACE STICK TO. LOCAL PARK
REQUIRE FOR HOW. YOU KNOW I
KNOW THIS FROM MY COMMITTEE A
NUMBER TEMPLE IN THE CAN. I
WANT TO DO THEY CAN DO WHETHER
<c.red>T'S HOME FOLKS ALLOW THEM TO</c>
PARK OVERNIGHT. FORTY YEARS ON
THE LARGER PARKING. TO BE ABLE
BE A FOR OUR- AND SAW THESE
EMPTY PARK LOTS FOR WANT TO EAT
THAT'S- HOUSING. AND SO. BUT OF
IS KNOW PLANS TO BUILDHOUSE ON
REALLY PROPER OFF SPACE
ROADBLOCK. ONE OF THE CALM IS
THE- TO. OF PROPERTIES TO
RESIDUE PARK REQUIRE. DUE TO A-
LOW ORDER. THE INCREASED. COSTS
FINISH BERRY FOR THESE PROFITS
LIKE WE IS. THAT WOULD LIKE TO
IN THE HOW SO. IT WILL FOR THE
REDUCTIONS MEASURE WILL ALLOW
FOR THE REDUCTION OF
RESIDENTIAL PARKING
REQUIREMENTS ON THESE RELIGIOUS
PROPERTIES AND AGAIN AS I SAY.
HELP STIMULATE PRODUCTION
HOUSING CALIFORNIA SO
DESPERATELY NEEDS ASK YOUR
RIVAL. WE HAVE A- LOS ROOM- A
FROM THE CALIFORNIA BE. AS THE
WITNESS ON THE OF ASSEMBLY.
WITH THANK YOU MUCH AND IT A
NEW BABY GIRL NAME HELLA.
PERFECT ELOISE. ABSOLUTELY
GREAT IN BE A THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN YOU'LL BE. THE IN THE AND
SO WITH PARKING KARMA I MENTION
THAT THE ON. ONE OR THIS ONE
INTO CHECK THANK WHICH- CENTERS
FOR GOING TO THINK RELEASE IN
IN HER STAFF BEEN SO GREAT.
EACH ONE OF THREE MINUTES LET'S
CHECK IN THAT A MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA BE
ON THE LINE. YES AND THE LINE
IS OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR- YET YOU
BEAT ME TO IT I WAS EXCITED TO
JUMP IN AND AROUND THE- MATTER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE COULD NEW
DAUGHTER ELLY VERY HEALTHY
BEAUTIFUL BUT ON TWITTER CUTE.
MY NAME IS LOUIS I'M WITH CAL
IN THE OUT OF RISK TO THE
COMMITTEE I'M GONNA TRY TO KEEP
MY COMMENTS BRIEF TONIGHT I
WANTED THANK OUR NIGHT A DOCTOR
NOON BY ONE OF THE THINK THE-
MAJORITY LEADER FOR DOING A
VERY ACT A JOB IN DESCRIBING
THE BELL. CALIFORNIA BE IS
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR A BEATING
FIND OUT PART BECAUSE WE FIND
IT MEETING. FUNDING. WE REALLY
WANT TO MAKE IT EASIER ADD. THE
OKAY COMMUNITY AROUND CAL. AND
TO HELP THEM BUILD PARKING IN
THE IN THE PLACES WHERE THEY- I
THINK IT BE A PART FOR THEIR-
AB FIFTY ONE A UNIQUE FROM A-
EIGHT NINE NINE IN THE- THAT IT
EIGHT IN THE- ONE ALLOWS. A
COMMUNITY USED YOU TO PARK LOT
THAT WOULD BE THE RISE REQUIRED
FOR. THE PRINT. OF FATE
BUILDING THE OR THE PENTAGON IN
THE APPLE I'M TO ME IT. WORK.
AND THIS ALLOWS STATE
COMMUNITIES VIEWS. IF THAT THEY
ARE USING PER SHE WORSHIP DAY
HI TO HELP THEM OUT BRING THEIR
CONGREGATE WITH CLOSER WALK
THAT THE TO THE PLATE THE
WORSHIP. WE WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
REALLY COOL ON THE BILL AND
WRITING REALLY HELPFUL BACK. IN
YOUR SUPPORT FOR BEACON. GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATORS ARE
WONDERFUL DAY TO YOU ALL
GRADUALLY. BUT THE WORKS AS
WELL AND I AGAIN WILL BE BRIEF
AND HIGHLIGHT JUST ONE EXAMPLE
OF A PROJECTSITE THAT WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THE PASSAGE OF AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE. ONE OF
THOUSANDS ACROSS THE GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS SITE
IS OWNED BY CENTER POLK
COMMUNITY CHURCH IN IS
CERTAINLY UNDER UTILIZED
PARKING LOT- THE PARKING LOT IS
ROUGHLY ACRE LARGE AND NOW
FIFTY PARKING SPACES ON IT.
IT'S DIRECTLY ACROSS THE STREET
FROM THE CENTURY BUILDING AND
THE PASSAGE OF AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY ONE WILL ALLOW THIS SITE
AND- THE CHURCH TO PURSUE.
DEVELOPING A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE UNITS UNDER DENSITY BONUS
ON THIS SITE. AND LIKELY THAT
WOULD KEEP ALL OF THE FIFTY
PARKING SPACES THAT ARE THERE
TODAY JUST ONE EXAMPLE THAT
WOULD BENEFIT FROM THIS BILL
AND STRONGLY SUPPORT A CREATING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING HUNDRED AND
HE THOUGHT IT IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR WORK AND
WISH YOU A WONDERFUL AFTERNOON.
YOU KNOW NICE JOB LEWIS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
BOTH OUR LEAD WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
ONE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
COMMITTEE WE ARE NOW GOING TO
BE GOING TO OUR TELEPHONES IF
YOU'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
COMMENT TODAY ON ANY OF OUR
BILLS PLEASE DIAL EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE
SIX FOUR. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR
DIAL THE CODE THAT IS CURRENTLY
ON YOUR SCREEN NOW WE LOOK.
FORWARD TO HEARING. WHEN WE GO
INTO LIVE LINE AND ASK MARK TO
PLAY QUEUE UP. ALL OF THOSE WHO
ARE IN. AND A EIGHT. FOR ONE
MATTER MODERATOR. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO COMMON IN FAVOR OF
AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN FAVOR OF AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. OUR FIRST COMMON
COMES FROM MINE FORTY SEVEN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE PHILADELPHIA CRANK CALLING
ON BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY AT
HOME IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS TODAY MET A MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON. BACK
AMERICA ON BEHALF AS LEADING H.
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISS MARK IS BETTER MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MADISON
DOLLY ON BEHALF OF THE SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS BOTH IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. AND MINE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON. HI
HOLLY FOR ME NEEDING A FIFTH OF
LIFE HEALTH PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING TODAY IN COURT ON
BEHALF OF THE THREE P. CAMPAIGN
WHICH INCLUDES THE SAN
FRANCISCO FUNDATION TEAM NEW
PARTNER THAN MANY OTHER
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA HOUSING
ADVOCATES. AS WELL AS HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA AND THE
THING BUT THE KOBE AREA
PLANNING AN URBAN RESEARCH
INSTITUTE ALL IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH HOLLY
THANKS FOR CALLING IN TODAY
MATTER MODERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND AT THIS TIME IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN FAVOR OF AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE. PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. THERE ARE NO.
FURTHER COMMENTS IN FAVOR OF A.
B. EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE. ARE I
THINK YOU SO MUCH AND WE'RE
GONNA REMIND ALL MEMBERS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP MASKS OVER
KNOWS IS HERE TODAY SO JUST A
QUICK REMINDER WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE GOING TO THOSE WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION OPPOSITION. AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE MATTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU BUT PLEASE
QUEUE UP THOSE WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION. IN OPPOSITION ON
OUR LIVE LINE OF AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU AND IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION HANK
YOU SO MUCH WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO MADE LIKE
TO BE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND
OR OPPOSITION IN EITHER OF THE
ROOMS THAT WE ARE OPERATING IN
TODAY. FIRST AND FOREMOST WE'RE
GONNA START RIGHT HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE AT
THIS TIME. KAREN SEEN NO ONE
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEE IF WE
HAVE ANYONE ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WANTING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. WE SEE NO ONE WE'RE
NOW GOING TO BRING IT. BACK TO
COMMITTEE. FOR CONVERSATION.
BUT COMMITTEE MEMBERS QUESTIONS
CONVERSATION OR WOULD ANYONE
LIKE TO BE TO OFFER A MOTION
OFFER A MOTION FOR THE BILL. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR BELT
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR BELL-
THIS MOTION BY SENATOR BILLS DO
PASS IS A NEEDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. MR MAJORITY
LEADER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
PLEASE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
JUST TEST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU FOR THE
DESCRIPTION THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER MAJORITY LEADER GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR WORK SIR. WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR. EMOTIONAL
FLOOR BY SENATOR BAIL ON A. B.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE DO PASSES
AMENDED HER PREPARATIONS. MR
NOW CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR MCGUIRE HI
MCGUIRE HI A SENATOR MORE LOCK.
OR UNLOCK FIVE SENATOR BELL.
BELL HI SENATOR HERTZBERG BY.
FOR HI SENATOR HURTADO. HI
RICARDO HI SENATOR NIELSEN.
SENATOR WINNER. WIENER HI CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE OF THE
NUMBERS ONE MORE TIME PLEASE
CONSERVATIVE SENATOR NIELSEN.
ALL RIGHT THAT IS A SIX ZERO
VOTE SIX ZERO VOTE THANK YOU SO
MUCH THAT BILL HAS PASSED. IN
WE ARE CLOSING THE RULES
ALRIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
THE CENTER HERTZBERG SHOW IS
JUST ABOUT TO CONCLUDE WE HAVE
ONE MORE BILL THOUGH ONE MORE
BILL AND THAT IS- ARE SIX ITEM
ON OUR ACTION AGENDA TODAY THIS
IS AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE WHICH WE
PULLED FROM CONSENT. IS
MAJORITY LEADER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK. THANK YOU
THE- SHERMAN YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES IN THIS JOB IS
WE OFTEN HAVE COMPETING
INTERESTS. BOTH LEGITIMATE AND
WE GOT TO MAKE TOUGH DECISIONS.
HERE WE'VE GOT DISTURBED
TREMENDOUS DEMAND FOR WILD
FIRES. AND THE IMPACT IT HAS IN
THE FACT THAT WE RELIED SO
HEAVILY ON WIRELESS SYSTEMS
THESE MACRO TOWERS IS BIG
TOWERS. THAT OPERATE YOUR CELL
PHONES SO THERE'S A FIRE
THERE'S SOME KIND OF EVENT YOU
NEED ACCESS TO. YOUR TELEPHONE
TECHNOLOGY. ON THE OTHER HAND
WE'VE GOT ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. AND SO
WHAT THIS BILL DEALS WITH IN MY
JUDGMENT IS. GIVING AN
EXPEDITED PROCESS TO INSTALL
BACKUP POWER FOR THESE BIG
STATIONS AYE IN MY DAY I USED
TO DO SOLAR AND WIND AS OPPOSED
TO ANY KIND OF FOSSIL FUEL
BACKUP POWER FOR THESE KINDS OF
STATIONS AROUND THE GLOBE BUT
I'M QUITE FAMILIAR WITH THIS
ISSUE. AND SO WHAT WHAT IT DOES
TO PUT TO SIXTY A SHOT CLOCK IF
YOU WILL TO ALLOW FOR THE
APPROVAL OF THIS SO THAT WE
CAN- IS THE WILDFIRES IF YOU
KNOW THREATEN US AND THE LIKE.
WILL ENABLE RAPID THE POINT
EMERGENCY STANDBY GENERATORS
WHICH OF COURSE AS WE ALL KNOW
IS VITAL TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
AND WELFARE TO ENSURE THAT
CONSUMERS- MAINTAIN ACCESS TO
NINE ONE ONE. AND SO THERE'S
BEEN SOME DISCUSSION I KNOW
THAT THIS ASSEMBLY OR CORPORATE
STILL WILLING TO. DISCUSS
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS AS THIS
MOVES ALONG TO THE PROCESS. BUT
IT DOES APPLY TO MACRO TOWERS
DOES NOT APPLY TO THIS THE
SMALLER FIVE G. OR A DEALS
ORDER SMALL CELL TOWERS. AND
GET YOU KNOW WHAT DOES APPLY
STATE WIDE WHICH IS ONE OF THE
CONSIDERATIONS HERE. BUT
CLEARLY THERE HAVE BEEN
CHALLENGES ALL ACROSS THE STATE
IF YOU LOOK FOR EXAMPLE AT THE-
THERE WAS AN ORDER THAT WAS
DONE I'M TRYING TO FIND IT TO
THE ORDER THAT DEALT WITH THIS
IN TWO THOUSAND. AND NINETEEN
OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
THE P. S. P. S. ORDER WHICH
IMPACTED COMMUNITY STABILIZE.
FOR THE GETS A BALANCED
APPROACH DEALING WITH
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES DEALING
WITH THE ISSUES OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. BUT OVERRIDING
PUBLIC SAFETY ACCESS TO NINE
ONE ONE. ACT TWO IS THE
CHAIRMAN THOSE AS WELL AS
ANYBODY THE DEVASTATION FROM
THESE FIRES SO WITH THAT. I
WOULD ASK FOR AN I. MR MAJORITY
LEADER THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY SINCERELY AND
THANKS FOR DOING THESE FOR
BILLS ON BEHALF OF THE THREE
AUTHORS TODAY LAYS IN GERMAN
COMMITTEE- AND WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH OUR PHONE LINES WE
TO LEAD WITNESSES ON OUR PHONE
LINES- AND THAT'S MISSING
TENER. ENTRIES THE RHINE
MISSING TEN IS FROM EIGHTEEN T.
THEN WE'RE GONNA GO TO TREAT
YOU WANT RUNNING WITH RC RC
EACH WILL HAVE THREE MINUTES
LET'S START WITH METTA
MODERATOR MATTER RIGHT
MODERATOR I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE BOTH ARE TO LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESSES CUED UP AND
READY TO GO MADAME MODERATOR
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
AND BOTH LINES ARE OPEN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH WHEN WE START WITH
MISSING TENER FROM EIGHTEEN T.
THEN WE'LL GO TO TREAT YOU
RUNNING FROM RC RC MISSING
TENANTS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERING THE-
MEASURE TODAY. MY NAME IS
SUSAN. AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF AGENCY TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE. WHICH
WOULD STRENGTHEN PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS BY ENABLING
FASTER DEPLOYMENT BACKUP POWER
SOLUTIONS AT MACWORLD CELL
TOWERS. AFTER POWER ESPECIALLY
TIMES OF EMERGENCY IS A SHARE
FOR THE STATE FOR COMMUNITY AND
COURSE FOR IN. PROVIDERS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK HAS
WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH MANY
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE CPUC
COMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERSAND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION.
IN RESOLVING ANY CONCERNS WITH
THE SCOPE AND JURISDICTION OF
THE VERY NARROWLY AILORED
MEASURE. TO EXPEDITE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF BACKUP POWER
SOLUTIONS. THE FOR THIS REASON
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE
ENJOYS INCREASINGLY WIDESPREAD
SUPPORT FROM PUBLIC SAFETY
ORGANIZATIONS SHERIFFS AS WELL
AS FIRE CHIEF ACROSS THE STATE.
AS YOU ALL KNOW LAST OCTOBER
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCE. THE
ACCIDENTS THAT WERE
UNPRECEDENTED AND- AND GAIL
THESE EXTENDED COMMERCIAL POWER
OUTAGES HAVE SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE INCLUDING
ON TELECOMMUNICATIONS NETWORK.
SH AS WE NAVIGATE THE IMPACTS
OF A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
COMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS AT THE
MAKING SIGNIFICANT. FOR THE
WILDFIRE SEASON AND THE FUTURE
POSSIBILITY OF WIDESPREAD PHP
AFTER THAT EVEN AS WE SPEAK
TODAY WILDFIRES ARE ALREADY
UNDER WAY AND BRETT MEANS A LOT
TO POLITICAL POWER THE
COMMUNICATION FACILITY.
ACTUALLY I WE'RE DOING OUR PART
TO MAKE SURE OUR NETWORK
RANGERS BILLION IN THE FACE OF
SUCH CATASTROPHIC IMPACTS. WE
ARE IMPLEMENTING GOAL TIME HERE
CAPITAL INVESTMENT PROGRAM THAT
INCLUDES LOU FIXED AND LOCAL
GENERATORS BACKUP BUT GRAYSON
MUCH MORE INTERESTING HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TOWARD
THE STAFFER HOWEVER.
INCONSISTENT PERMITTING
REQUIREMENTS CROSS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SHOULD BE WORKING
FINE THIRD. SOURCE OF DELAY.
THIRTY SIX WE NEED YOUR HELP.
EIGHT RAPIDLY IT SHE THE GOAL
OF IMPROVING POWER SITE HI
FUTURE COMMERCIAL SHUT OFF
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SPEAK UP THE
LOCAL PERMITTING. WALL STREET
FINAL FOR A WITH A CHURCH.
PERMITTING FEES REIMBURSE BUT
PAID TO LOCAL AGENCY WILL NOT
BE IF BY THIS BUDGET. AND FOR
THE MORE AT DOORS OPEN SEVERAL
AMENDMENTS ACCEPTED BY THE
AUTHOR WELL LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION FOR INDIVIDUAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL EIGHT CAMPAIGN PUBLIC
SAFETY PARTNERS ARE COMMITTED
TO PROVIDING COMMUNICATION
SERVICES THAT THE PUBLIC IN
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES. CAN
TRUST AND RELY ON AND WE LOOK
WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN LEADING
OPERA AND TWENTY TWENTY. TO
EXPAND OUR SHARED GOAL OF A
RELIABLE AND RESILIENT
COMMUNICATION DURING WILDFIRES.
THAT ANY OTHER MERCHANTS THE
WHITE RIGHT NOT BEAUTIFUL
EIGHT. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
REQUIRE AND TO SENATOR
HERTZBERG PRESENTING THIS BILL
AND ALL THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY AND I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO SAY THAT. IN
ADDITION TO BEING OPEN TO YOUR
QUESTION. SEVEN OUR NETWORK
EXPERT LEADING MATCH LONG. ON
THE FOR TO CANCER ANY BUT-
TECHNICAL QUITE THAT MAY ARISE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS
INTERNET MISSING FROM. T. LAYS
AND GENTLEMAN COMMITTEE WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO OUR SECOND AND
FINAL LEAD WITNESS ON THIS BILL
THAT STREETS YOU WEREN'T TRYING
FROM RC RC. PRECEDE THE LINE.
IS OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON. HI TRACY MY
WELCOMING. A CAL. REPRESENTING
THIRTY SEVEN MEMBER COUNTY. AS
YOU KNOW WORLD COUNTY TO HIT
VERY HARD LAST YEAR BY NUMEROUS
YES. AND YET THE BAD AND THE
SUBSEQUENT INSIGNIFICANT
TELECOMMUNICATION OUTAGES. LOTS
OF ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE WITH
LOVED ONES ARE RECEIVING COURT
INFORMATION ON ENERGY OUTAGES
ARE PENDING DISASTER SUCH AS A
WILDFIRE IS IMPORTANT ALL
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS BUT EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT AT TIMES TO
THOSE IN RURAL AREAS THAT ARE
AT GREATER RISK OF AN ACCIDENT
AFTER. A SPECIALLY DURING YES
YES THE BAND WHEN THE
CONDITIONS FOR WILD FIRE MORE
PREVALENT. EIGHTY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE CASH OR A STREAM
PERMITTING PROCESS FOR BACKUP
POWER GENERATORS CITING AT BACK
ON HEALTH- TOWER SITE. HE WOULD.
NOT A MORE SUPPORTIVE MEASURE
LIKE THIS ONE THAT REMOVES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ABILITY TO
MAKE DISCRETIONARY LANYARD
SUFFICIENT- HOWEVER THIS BILL
IS NARROWLY CRAFTED. AND
PROVIDE IMPORTANT SAFEGUARDS
SUCH AS ALLOWING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IN FORCE HEALTH
AND SAFETY REQUIREMENTS FOR
PERMITTING. LIMITING
APPLICABILITY TO SPECIFIC TYPES
OF GENERATORS. LIMITING THE
EXIST TO EXISTING BUT BY IT
ALSO INCLUDES A PROVISION WHICH
LIMITS THE DURATION OF THE
STREAMLINED PERMITTING PROCESS.
WHEN THE BENEFITS OF THE BILL
AGAINST THE LIMITS INSTITUTED
ON A MEMBER COUNTY PERMITTING
DECISION IT WAS CLEAR EIGHTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE WAS AND
THE COULD HELP WORLD COUNTY
COMMUNICATION SYSTEMS ONLINE
DURING THE NEXT POWER OUTAGE.
WE ARE GREATLY APPRECIATIVE TO
THE DOCTOR'S OFFICE AND THE
SPONSORS FOR ENGAGING RC RC TO
ADDRESS OUR TECHNICAL CONCERNS
WITH THAT THOUGH AND WE'RE VERY
HAPPY TO OFFER OUR SUPPORT ON
EIGHTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE
AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH IS RYAN
THAT'S RISKY RYAN FROM RC RC
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO IN
PERSON CONTACT INFORMATION
COMMENT WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR
FIRST AND LAST NAME ALONG WITH
YOUR ORGANIZATION WE'RE GONNA
START RIGHT HERE IN FORTY TWO
OH THREE SIR GOOD AFTERNOON
PERSON LASSEN ORGANIZATION
THANK YOU FOR COMING IN TODAY.
MR TURN RESULTS FOR US WAS
STRATEGIES THREE SIXTY ON
BEHALF OF TECHNO AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE TAURUS
IS TO BE WITH YOU HERE TODAY
AND HAVE SOMEONE IN PERSON
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. I SEE WE WANT TO
ROOM TWO WOULD LIKE ME TO SPEAK
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE. HERE IN SEEN NO ONE
WOULD GOING TO GO TO ROOM. FOUR
ROOM FOR FORTY BE TO SEE
THROUGH ANYONE. WHO LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF WHAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE AND NO- HERE AND SEEN
KNOW WHEN WE'RE NOT GOING TO.
TURN TO OUR PHONE LINES WE'RE
GONNA GO TO OUR PHONE LINES IN
SEE IF WE HAVE OUR- LEAD
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. BUT
THAT'S GOT DANNY GOOD HERE IS
FROM. THE FEDERAL PEOPLE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA EXCUSE ME.
AMERICA DANNY GOOD TWO YEARS.
IS SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION META
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE OUR LEAD
OPPOSITION. OF AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE IN THE QUEUE. ED MR
TEARS IF YOU WOULD PRESS STAR
AND THEN ZERO WE CAN TAKE YOUR
NAME. IF YOUARE JOINED AS A
PARTICIPANT ON THE CALL.
CURRENTLY LOOKING FOR DANNY
GOOD DEAREST ANY GOOD TWO YEARS
FOR THE COMMUNICATION WORKERS
OF AMERICA AND STAR IN AN ZERO
TO BE ABLE TO GET CUED UP
SPEAKING AS OUR LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE. MATTER MODERATOR
ALTERNATE BACK TO YOU. AND IS
THERE ANY CURE TERRACE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON IS A GOOD TEARS
DURING COMMITTEE YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US. AND CHECK BACK
WITH THE MODERATOR META
MODERATOR TO WITNESS TO BE
TEARS ON THE LINE. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. FRIDAY'S IN GERMAN THE
MODERATOR IS GONNA BE QUEUING
UP IT'S A GOOD YEAR IS IF YOU'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE A
COMMENT HERE TODAY YOU CAN
ALWAYS DIAL. 844-291-6364.
844-291-6364 WERE CURRENTLY IN
OPPOSITION OPPOSITION COMMENTS
ON THE TELEPHONE ON AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY ONE MATTER
MODERATOR UNDER TURN IT BACK
OVER TO YOU HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE
TO. LOCATE MISTER GOOD TEARS. I
HAVE NOT A IT. WAS A PERSON
THAT JUST NEEDED TO- COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT. SO WE DO
NOT HAVE MISTER GOOD YEARS WITH
THIS AT THIS TIME SO NOW WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS WE'RE GOING
TO GO INTO GENERAL OSITION
ON THE TELEPHONE LINE. GENERAL
OPPOSITION ON THE TELEPHONE
LINE. IF YOU COULD PLEASE STATE
YOUR FIRST AND LAST NAME ALONG
WITH YOUR ORGANIZATION WE'D BE
GRATEFUL. MADAME MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP THOSE WHO
ARE IN OPPOSITION. OF AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY ONE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS MEANT A MODERATOR. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE PRESS ONE AND THEN
THERE AT THIS TIME. NINE FIFTY.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON. MEMBERS I
APOLOGIZE I MEANT TO CALL
EARLIER IN THE SUPPORT
POSITIONS- THE JONATHON FELDMAN
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE- COLLEGE AS WE GET IN
THE WRONG HERE. YOU'RE ALL GOOD
MISTER FELDMAN IT'S GOOD TO
HEAR YOU WE HAVE JUST LOG THAT
MR FELDMAN IN THE CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER FELDAN GOOD TO HEAR
YOUR VOICE SIR. MATT A
MODERATOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION OR WILL TAKE THOSE
HERE IN SUPPORT IT'S ALL GOOD-
THE FLOOR IS YOURS MADE A
MODERATOR ALL RIGHT. ONLY
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS-
LIKE- MISTER FELDMAN I MEANT TO
CALL IN FOR THE SPORT MY NAME
IS RICHARD WILL GET WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. SO GOOD
RICHARD THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS NOT A
MODERATOR LET'S JUST SAY WE'RE
GONNA TAKE ANYBODY AND
EVERYBODY SO WE'RE GONNA TAKE
THOSE ARE IN SUPPORT THOSE WHO
MAY BE SQUISHY AS WELL AS THOSE
WHO MAY BE OPPOSE. BETTER
MODERATOR TO HAVE ANYONE ELSE.
COMMENT ON AB. TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE. YES WE HAVE LINE
TWENTY SEVEN MY TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. AND AS I'M
ACTUALLY THE DESIGNATED
OPPOSITION FOR THIS BILL AND
NOT AFTER COULD GET HER SO THIS
IS THE NOT SURE HERNANDEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT
NINE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
IF I COULD MAKE A FEW BRIEF
COMMENTS YES SURE DO APOLOGIZE
IS HERNANDEZ THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE HAD MISTER GOOD TEARS HIS
NAME BUT THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR
YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. MAKE A QUICK-
CHAIR MEMBERS OF HIS IF YOU A
DISTRICT NINE. HAVE A LONG
RECORD OF FIGHTING FOR BACKUP
POWER. SEE OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS CREATED
CALIFORNIA ON BOTH THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND GET THE CORRECT
CQC HOW WE CAN TO ME THOSE
EFFORTS IN THE PUSH FOR.
GREATER BACKUP POWER GREATER
RESILIENCE IN THE
COMMUNICATIONS FOR IT.
UNFORTUNATELY WE CANNOT SUPPORT
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE IN ITS
CURRENT FORM WE'VE BEEN OPPOSED
TO THE BILL FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING. AND BYZANTINE
KITCHEN WITH THE OFFERS OFFERED
THROUGHOUT. BOB BARKER IS
PRIMARILY THE ON STERN LINE OF
THE BILL. I CERTAINLY. UNDER OR-
WITH. FORTY CCC AND OTHER
PUSHES LECTURE BACK UP POWER ON
THE WAY TO BEING STRAPPED THAT
IS REQUIRED THE GENERATOR THE
STATE. REQUIREMENTS WHAT IT
DOES NOT MAKE CLEAR THAT THE
USE THE GENERATORS CONSISTENT
WITH STATE POLICY OR STATE LAW
OUR STATE REGULATIONS WHICH IS
CRITICALI'M JUST A FEW DAYS
AGO. THE COMMISSION ADOPTED
WITH. YOU SEE A DOCTOR. ABOUT
THE POWER AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE. THAT THE GENERATOR THAT
IN VOCAL TO THIS PROPERTY
COMMITTED. IF FOR SOME REASON
IN VAIN CONSISTENT WITH WHAT
THE CONDITION OF THE HOUSE FOR.
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT WE KEEP
THE POWER TO WITHDRAW THAT
PERMIT- SOME SYNERGY BETWEEN
SEVENTEEN POSSIBLE. AND THE
COMMISSION REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE IN PLACE NOW AND WHAT MADE
YOU COME IN PLACE GOING FORWARD
IN ADDITION THE NUMBER OF
LEGISLATIVE EFFORT. INVOLVING
FROM THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
STUDENT PUSH BACK. ONE GREATER
BACK UP POWER MONTHLY TO. ABOUT
POTENTIAL. NUMBER THE FILM BE A
IN ONE MAKE SURE THAT THE BILL
IS THE- WITH THOSE BY ENOUGH
BUT- AND- ACCOUNTABILITY. THAT
YOU COULD BE GENERATED NOT
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT IT'S
REQUIRED BY THE COMMISSION WE
ARE IN THE SHOULD HELP PUSH
BACK. ON THE COMMISSION'S
ABILITY TO- TO REQUIRE CERTAIN
ABOUT THE POLISH SO WE'RE JUST
NOT QUITE THERE YET. I'M WITH
THE LANGUAGE YOU WANT THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME. HERNANDEZ THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR WORKING WITH
THIS TODAY WE APPRECIATE YOU
HANG IN AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS WE TRULY ARE GRATEFUL.
FOR YOU BEING WITH US THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER HERNANDEZ SETS.
NASSER HERNANDEZ SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE BUT A MODERATOR
LET'S GO BACK TO THOSE WHO MAY
BE IN THE QUEUE IF YOU CAN JUST
GIVE US AN UPDATE. HOW MANY
FOLKS ARE IN THE QUEUE OPPOSED
OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE AND IF YOU COULD
PLEASE DO A LAST CALL. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. IN
NINE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON. HELLO
EVERYONE MY NAME IS TODD
FRAZIER AND ON THE PRESIDENT OF
THE FRESNO POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION AND I'M ASKING YOU
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL IT'S
VITALLY IMPORTANT FOR
COMMUNICATIONS OUT THE RURAL
AREAS- WHERE OFFICERS MAYBE-
GET CALL TO PROVIDE- ASSISTANCE
AND WILD FIRES AND- WE THINK-
THE ONLY SAYS- COMMUNICATIONS
OF THOSE AVAILABLE CELLULAR.
AND WE NEED THIS- BILL TO PASS
THANK YOU AGAIN WE REALLY-APPRECIATE YOU CALLING IN THANK
YOU SO MUCH SIR AND TO PLEASE
GIVE OUR BEST TO EVERYONE IN
THE DEPARTMENT AS WELL THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENT. I
MADE A MODERATOR LET'S TAKE OUR
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. NINE FORTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE NINE FORTY SURE
THANK YOU AND NINE THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD
AFTERNOON. HI MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AARON READ REPRESENTING
POOR ACT VERY PROUD TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL ONE IDENTIFY WITH
SUSAN SANTANA'S COMMENTS
EARLIER- I DON'T KNOW WHY I
CAME IN LATE BUT- I I'M GLAD TO
BE ABLE TO SAY THAT BLACK IS
VERY HAPPY TO WORK WITH
EIGHTEEN ANTI THEY HAVE SHOWN.
A GREAT SUPPORT FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY FOR BOTH LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND FIRE BOTH THANK YOU HISTORY
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE HOPE
YOU'RE IN YOUR HAWAIIAN SHIRT
TODAY WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL- FOR
YOU COMING TEEN IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE.
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION WILL TAKE
IT ALL ON AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
ONE MADAME MODERATOR. NINE
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE BOARD- MY NAME SCOTT
WESTRA FROM THE DEPUTY FIRE
CHIEF FOR THE CITY OF SANTA
ROSA. ABOUT THE FIRE CHIEF IN
THE CITY CENTERS APART
APARTMENT AS PART OF SONOMA
COUNTY OPERATIONAL AREA WE
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CHIEF WE'RE GRATEFUL
PLEASE GIVE OUR BEST SAID TO
TONY- MR COSTNER'S WELL WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CALLING AND MET
A MODERATOR AT PLEASE LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. NINE FIFTY
FIVE NINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK YOU
MY NAME IS EFFORT VARGAS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IN
JUST TWO WORDS OF THIS REGARDS
THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS MR
VARGAS- IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY ONE. BETTER
MODERATOR LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD
AFTERNOON. LINE FORTY SIX YOUR
LIVE IN COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT
NOT A MODERATOR LET'S CHECK IN
HOW MANY FOLKS ARE IN THE QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS IN Q. BETTER MODERATOR
CAN YOU DO AS A FAVOR AND DO
ONE LAST LAST FINAL CALL FOR
THOSE WHO LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE OF AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU AND
FOR THOSE IN FAVOR OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN IN
FAVOR OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. NINE FORTY
SIX IF YOU WOULD PRESS THEIR
YOUR L<c.cyan>G FORTY SIX YOUR LINE</c>
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
AFTERNOON YES MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON JOINT
COMMITTEE REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE. IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS SIR THANK YOU FOR
CALLING IN TODAY. META
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
IN Q. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH MATTER MODERATOR WE ARE
STILL FORMALLY IN OPPOSITION
BUT BECAUSE WE HAD SOME LAST
MINUTE QUEUES INTO THE PHONE
LINE- WE TOOK BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION BUT WE ARE GOING TO
CONCLUDE OUR OPPOSITION-
TESTIMONY BY SEEN IF THERE'S
ANYONE HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE. HEARING
AND SEEING NO ONE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE GOING TO THE LONELY
IS ROOM IN THE CAPITOL AS WE
CALL IT ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE
IS NO ONE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE TO BEAR TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR ANYONE WHO WOULD.
BE TO MAKE A MOTION. BONTA
MOTION UP FAR WITH THE A MOTION
BY THE VICE CHAIR. THE MOTION-
BY VICE CHAIR MORLOCK IS DO
PASTOR PREPARATIONS- ON AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE THE
MAJORITY LEADER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I WOULD IN ALL ANSWER
SOME QUESTIONS THAT WERE RAISED.
YOU KNOW THE NOTION ABOUT-
WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH. CURRENT LAW SB
FIVE SIXTY MANDATES THAT
COMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS
PROVIDE RELEVANT SITUATIONAL
INFORMATION DURING THE OUTAGES
TO PUBLIC SAFETY STAKEHOLDERS
SB SIX SEVENTY MANDATES THE
REPORTING OF NETWORK OUTAGES TO
CAL OVER YES FOR WIRELINE
WIRELESS WHICH IS HERE VOICE
SERVICES WITHIN SIXTY MINUTES
OF DISCOVERY. IT'S MY JUDGMENT
IN TERMS OF THE ARGUMENT THAT'S
BEING MADE THAT TO ADD A
PROVISION THAT SAYS CONSISTENT
IS NOTHING MORE THAN ADDING A
PROVISION INVITES LITIGATION.
IT OFTEN LITIGATION IS
IMPORTANT WHAT YOU WANT TO
INVITE THE JUDICIAL BRANCH TO
DECIDE ON THINGS LIKE THIS. BUT
WE'RE FACING EMERGENCIES THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILLS ABOUT WILDFIRES
PEOPLE HAVING ACCESS TO NINE
ONE ONE THAT'S WHY YOU HEARD SO
MANY FIREFIGHTERS IN PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICIALS STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. OFTEN
IN THE BALANCE THAT I TALKED
ABOUT OF THE OPENING HERE THAT
WE HAVE TO MEET WHEN YOU'RE
TRYING TO MEET THESE KINDS OF
EMERGENCIES INVITING LITIGATION
BUT JUST SIMPLY ALLOWS PARTIES
TO THEN GO TO A COURT AND
SAYING THERE'S AN
INCONSISTENCY. WHICH THE COURTS
MANDATED TO TAKE BECAUSE WE
SAID IN THE LEGISLATION IS
NOTHING MORE IN MY JUDGMENT
THAN A DELAY IN THE PROCESS.
AND I WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
OF THIS IMPORTANT MISSION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
LEADER HEARD- GET IT AND I SO
THE MOTION BY THE VICE CHAIR IS
TO PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS MISTER
NOW ROLL CALL PLEASE. SENATOR
MCGUIRE HI WITH WIRE- A SENATOR
MORLOCK BY FOUR O'CLOCK HI
SENATOR BILL. BELL HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG HI GOOD. FOR FIVE
SENATOR HURTADO. IN ORDER
NIELSEN HI HILLS AND HI SENATOR
WIENER. WIENER HI THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND MISTER NOW THAT
CURRENTLY IS A SIX ZERO WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE OPENED
ALLOW MISTER TODD- TO BE ABLE
TO ADD ON I DO KNOW THAT- THE
MAJORITY LEADER HAS ANOTHER
MEETING TO BE A TO GET TO BUT
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO- DO OUR
CONSENT CALENDAR AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN TO
ALLOW. MR TOMORROW TO BE ABLE
TO ADD ON WE HAVE SEVERAL ITEMS
ON YOUR MCCARTY QUICK QUESTION
YEAH I HAVE A FILE FOR AB TWO
SEVENTY SIX FRIEDMAN THE CAR'S
ACT CONFORMITY IS THAT STILL
MAINTAINED ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DAYS OF THAT YES THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR.
ABSOLUTELY SO WE HAVE SEVERAL
ITEMS ON OUR CONTENT COUNTERED
THAT GOES NOW TO THROUGH-
SIXTEEN THAT WE HAVE A MOTION
BY THE VICE CHAIR A MOTION BY
THE VICE CHAIR VICE CHAIR A LOT
HAS MOVED CONSENT CALENDAR- NOW
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
THE KITCHEN COUNTER. SENATOR HI.
ALRIGHT SO MORLOCK. FOR LOCK HI
SENATOR BY. BILL HI. HERTZBERG
BY HERTZBERG FIVE CENT HER TO.
SENATOR NIELSEN HI NIELSEN I
SENATOR WIENER WIENER HI THIS
GENERAL COMMITTEE THAT
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX YEAR
VOTE SIX ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THAT ROLL OPEN ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE'VE TO ITEMS
LEFT FOR OUR BUSINESS AGENDA
TODAY WE'RE GONNA START WITH
THIS IN THE MEMBER GRAY THIS IS
AB THIRTY THREE TWELVE A. B.
THIRTY THREE TWELVE. FOCUSING
ON THE ANNEXATION THE CITY
MERCED I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO BE TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
GOOD ASSEMBLY MAN FOR HIS WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE- GOING TO
TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO THE SIM
WOMEN TO BE A PRISON AB THIRTY
THREE TWELVE AND OF COURSE
ISN'T LIMóN WE BELIEVE YOU'RE
GONNA BE TAKING THE- IMMENSE
AND WE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
YOUR STAFF. AND YOUR SELF FOR
WORKING SO ARE. THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN AND BUT WE ALSO WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD
WORK OF BOTH COMMITTEE STAFF-
AND MY OFFICE IN GETTING THIS.
IN SHAPE TO MOVE FORWARD THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AB THIRTY THREE TELL TWELVE
PROVIDES IN THEIR EXEMPTION- TO
THE CURRENT ANNEXATION LAW TO
SUPPORT THE GROWTH OF UC MERCED
AND- IF I MIGHT ALL SHARE WITH
THE COMMITTEE A BRIEF HISTORY.
OF THE CAMPUS- IN MY HOMETOWN
AND THE GOOD MAJORITY LEADER
AND FORMER SPEAKER- CENTER
HERTZBERG- WAS ACTUALLY
INSTRUMENTAL IN BRINGING THE
TENTH AND MOST RECENT
UNIVERSITY OF MERCED CAMPUS. TO
REALITY AND- IT HAS BEEN AN
EXTRAORDINARY SUCCESS STORY YOU
KNOW A MAJORITY OF FIRST IN
THEIR FAMILY- TO GO TO COLLEGE
STUDENTS- A MAJORITY MINORITY
CAMPUS JUST- RIGHT FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA NOT TO
MENTION THE YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BUT THE WAY WE
ULTIMATELY GOT THAT CAMPUS
CITED A MERCED SOMEWHAT. I HAD
TO DO WITH THE STORY OF THE
VIRGINIA SMASH SMITH- TRUST
WHICH OWNED A RANCH IN MERCED
COUNTY DONATED THE LAND TO THE
STATE FOR THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE CAMPUS. AND I MYSELF AM A
RECIPIENT OF THE SCHOLARSHIP
FROM THE VIRGINIA SMITH TRUST
WHICH WAS A SCHOLARSHIP- TAKEN
FROM THE RANCH PROCEEDS AND
GIVEN TO STUDENTS OF MERCED
HIGH SCHOOL FOR MANY MANY
YEARS. A SCHOLARSHIP THE
CONTINUES TO THIS DAY. AND PART
OF THE- GOAL THERE WAS TO
DONATE LED TO THE STATE TO
BUILD THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE VALLEY. AND
THEN WITH THE SURROUNDING LAND-
STILL OWNED A MAINTAINED BY THE
TRUST. TO DEVELOP IT AND-
OBVIOUSLY. GET FUNDS TO FURTHER
SUPPORT YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
VALLEY IN THE CITY AND
HOPEFULLY LATER COUNTY OF
MERCED FOR COLLEGE SCHOLARSHIPS.
SO MANY YEARS LATER THROUGH A
GREAT RECESSION THROUGH THE
STATE CUTTING FUNDING TO HIGHER
EDUCATION AND- STATE MEAN THE
GROSS REALLY OF THE CAMPUSFOR
MANY MANY YEARS WE HAVE REACHED
TEN THOUSAND STUDENTS IT'S A
BEAUTIFUL CAMPUS IT'S ON A
SMALLER FOOTPRINT THAN WE
ORIGINALLY HAD ENVISIONED AS WE
DONATED THOUSANDS OF ACRES-
INTO CONSERVATION AROUND THE
CAMPUS. BUT THE CAMPUS WAS
CITED BECAUSE OF THIS FREE LAND
ON THE TRUST- FOR MILES AND-THOUSANDS OF ACRES AWAY FROM
THE CITY PERCENT. AND SO THE
SURROUNDING DEVELOPMENT OF THAT
CAMPUS THAT WOULD FEED BOTH
THAT TRUST AND ALSO CREATE
CAMPUS LIFE AN OPPORTUNITY
STUDENT FACULTY HOUSING HAS NOT
COME TO FRUITION- AS THE CITY.
THROUGH THE GREAT RECESSION
SLOWLY HAS BUILT OUT LET ME
REMIND THE MEMBERS DURING THE
GREAT RECESSION AND HOUSING
CRISIS MERCED WAS ON THE TOP
TEN LIST IN THE COUNTRY. NOT IN
THE STATE IN THE COUNTRY. I
JUST HIT BY THE HOUSING CRISIS
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF REASONS
THAT GROWTH HAS. NOT OCCURRED
IN THE WAY WE HAD HOPED OVER
THE YEARS AND WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD DO IS ALLOW THE CAMPUS
ITSELF A STATE INVESTMENT TO BE
ANNEXED INTO THE CITY. AND THEN
LET THE CITY AND THE CAMPUS
GROW TOGETHER WHICH WILL AFFORD
A STUDENT AND FACULTY LIFE
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL AS
FULFILL THE PROMISE OF THE
VIRGINIA SMITH. A SCHOLARSHIP
TRUST IN A EXPEDITED FASHION
WHICH IS THE GOAL THE PUBLIC
POLICY GOAL OF THE BILL AND I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION HAPPY TO TAKE.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ARE
RIGHT HERE ANY CONCERNS THIS
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND SOMEONE WE'RE WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
AND- IT'S VERY PERSONAL FOR
YOU- IN SO MANY IN THE
COMMUNITY SO GRATEFUL YOU'RE
BRINGING THIS FOURTEEN FINALLY-
ABLE TO BRING SOME CLOSURE TO
THIS IS WELL. FACING GENERAL
COMMITTEE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
EVERYTHING JUST FROM APOLOGIZE
I HAVE TO. RAISE TO A MEETING
BUT I WANTED TO BOTH MOVE THE
BILL. AND JUST EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR THIS
IS BEEN A BIG DEAL IT'S BEEN A
PART OF THIS FOR MANY YEARS
BEFORE HE EVEN WAS SERVED IN
GOVERNMENT AND BEEN IMPORTANT
ELEMENT IN THIS THIS CAMPUS AND
THE LAW WE WORKED ON MANY YEARS
AGO IS SO CRITICAL I JUST THANK
AND THANK HIM THANK AND DID A
GREAT JOB AND I WANT TO MOVE
THE BILL LIKE I'LL BE BACK. TO
VOTE ON IT THAT'S GOING TO HAVE
TO LEAVE SO APOLOGIST
INTERRUPTING THE FLOW OF YOUR
COMMITTEE SIR BUT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE I GOT THAT IN THANK
YOU SO MUCH JUSTIN HERTZBERG
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
WORK ON THIS- PRISON IN THOSE
OTHER BILLS AS WELL THAT LAYS
IN GENERAL COMMITTEE WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO IS WE HAVE THREE WAYS
TO BE A PARTICIPATE IN COMMENT
ON A. B. THIRTY THREE TWELVE
WE'RE GONNA BE GOING TO OUR
PHONE LINES IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE
A- COMMON IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSE.
PLEASE DIAL. 844-291-6364
YOU'RE GONNA WANT TO HIT THAT
PHONE NUMBER UP LET'S ON YOUR
SCREEN NOW IN DIAL THE CODE
WE'RE GONNA WELCOME TESTIMONY
RIGHT HERE IN FORTY TWO THREE
AS WELL AS IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SO LET'S GET THIS STARTED LET'S
TURN THIS OVER TO THE MODERATOR
AT A MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES ON THE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTY
THREE TWELVE MATTER MODERATOR
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
AND IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
FAVOR OF AB THIRTY THREE
TWELVE. PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN. FAVOR OF. AB
THIRTY THREE TWELVE. PRESS ONE
AND THEN GENERAL. AND OUR FIRST
LINE IN FAVOR OF A. B. THIRTY
THREE TWELVE IS NINE TWENTY
TWO. PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS THE TEACHER AND THE
RESPECT THAT IT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN OF SCHOOLS AND AS SUCH AND
ALSO APPOINTED TO BE THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
VIRGINIA SMITH TRUST. I WANT TO
ECHO WHAT- ARE SOME WOMEN
GREATEST SAID- THE UC MERCED
HAS DONE A FABULOUS JOB ABOUT
REACHING TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY
STUDENTS- WHICH IS AN-
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUP AMONG
THE UC STUDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE AND THEY'VE DONE A
FABULOUS JOB HERE UC MERCED. IN
SHOWING WHAT THEY CAN DO THE
VIRGINIA SPENT TRUST- PROMISED
TO WIN THE LAND WAS DONATED TO
THAT THEY WOULD BE PARTNERS
WITH THE UC SYSTEM AND WE'RE
WE'RE KEEPING OUR PROMISE WE'D
LOVE TO. DEVELOP AND HOUSING
ELEMENT RIGHT NEXT DOOR TO THE
UC CAMPUS THIS ANNEXATION AND
THE BILL WOULD POTENTIALLY
ALLOW US TO- CONNECT TO CITY
SEWER AND- MOVE FORWARD WITH
PROVIDING MUCH NEEDED HOUSING
IN THE CITY OF PER SAID ONLY
FOR THE STUDENTS OF ARE SAID.
TO BE MIXED USE HOUSING AND
PORTIONS AND WOULD ALLOW US TO
ALLEVIATE THE HOUSING SHORTAGE
IT IN MERCED THAT CURRENTLY
EXIST THE SCHOLARSHIP FUND GROW
BY OVER 25% BUT CURRENTLY WE
GIVE AWAY ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR THROUGH THE TRUST. WE
WOULD SEE THAT EXPANDING CLOSER
TO FIVE MILLION A YEAR ONCE OUR
COMMUNITY IS BUILT OUT ON OUR
PROPERTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AGAIN- IN FULL SUPPORT. OF AB
THIRTY THREE TWELVE. IS A SUPER
TEN WE YOUR NO I YOU ARE IN
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOU WERE ON
THIS. FROM FEAR COM THAT TO.
NEXT CALLER META MODERATOR.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
IN FAVOR OF AB THIRTY THREE
TWELVE. THE MODERATOR CAN WE DO
A QUICK ALL CALL LAST CALL FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY THREE TWELVE LAST CALL
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY THREE
TWELVE MIGHT A MODERATOR. THANK
YOU AND IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN FAVOR OF AB THIRTY THREE
TWELVE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH IF WE DO HEAR FROM A. B.
C. PACK ON BEHALF OF THE
VIRGINIA SMITH TRUST MATTER
MODERATOR FEEL FREE TO
INTERRUPT ME IN WILL MAKE TIME
FOR MISTER PECK IS WELL- WE ARE
NOW GOING TO GO TO. THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT I AM ON THE LINE.
ALL RIGHT STEVE PACKED AND
STEVE CAPTION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER PACKAGE GOOD
AFTERNOON SIR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS WE WELCOME YOU ARE TO
COMMITTEE YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON AUDIBLE CHAIRMAN
REQUIRED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. ON STEVEN PECKHAM
REPRESENTING BRIDGES TRUSTS
TODAY. AS MISTER IF YOU CAN
SAID THE ISSUE WITH YOUR TALK
GRANT FOR THE PROPERTY. THE UC
MERCED NOW OCCUPIES. BUT WHEN
YOU SEE MERCED BST PROVIDE LAW
IN THE STATE IT ALSO COMMUNITY
USE THE PROFITS. OF THE ELEMENT
OF ITS PROPERTY FOR
SCHOLARSHIPS BILL THAT PROMISE.
AB THIRTY THREE TWELVE WOULD
ENABLE BST TO INCREASE COLLEGE
SCHOLARSHIPS IN VERY
IMPORTANTLY TO EXPAND THE
PROGRAM TO THE TIRE COUNTY. AB
THIRTY THREE TWELVE WILL HELP
THE COMMUNITY FULFILL THE
PROMISE. MADE TO THE STATE
WOULD ALSO PROVIDE PROMISE AND
HOPE FOR HIGHER EDUCATION TO
FAMILIES. CANNOT NOW AFFORD ONE.
THE CITY AND COUNTY ALL SUPPORT
ANNEXATION OF YOU SEE IN THE
UNIVERSITY COMMUNITY
PROPERTIES. TO THE CITY
INCLUDING THE PST PROPERTY. AND
THEY ALONG WITH PERCENT JOHNNY
LAUGHED OKAY OR CALL THE
TRADITIONAL MEANS. OF ANNEXING
THE UC UNIVERSITY PROPERTIES.
EARLY PROVIDED BY STATE LAUGH
THE LAW. THE ONLY WITH THE
OPTIONS UNDER CURRENT STATE LAW
UC MERCED AND UNIVERSITY
COMMUNITY PLAN HERE YOU WILL
MOST LIKELY REMAIN IN THE
COUNTY. THIS IS NOT A DESIRABLE
OUTCOME MORE WONDERFUL FEELS A
LEGISLATIVE IN. THE STATE LAST
GO STATUTES. SB THIRTY THREE
TWELVE PROVIDES A CITY COUNTY
LAUGHTER WITH ANOTHER
RESPONSIBLE ALTERNATIVE OPTION.
TO ENSURE THAT URBAN SERVICES
ARE PROVIDED BY THOSE LOCAL
AGENCIES WHICH CONTEST
ACCOMMODATE BY THE NECESSARY
GLOBAL SERVICE. IN THE MOST
EFFICIENT MANNER POSSIBLE. WELL
BILLS ALREADY APPROVED FOR THE
UC AND FOR THE UNIVERSITY
PROPERTIES. SB THIRTY THREE
TWELVE ALLOWED TO SIT IN THE
COUNTY CHIEF YOUR CENTRAL
LEGISLATIVE INTENT. A CYCLICAL
LAW TO THE CITY OF MERCED CAN
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY SERVICES
IN THE MOST EFFICIENT MANNER.
WE ASK YOUR APPROVAL SB THIRTY
THREE TWELVE AS AMENDED. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER PECK WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR YOU HANG IN WITH
US THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK ON BEHALF THE TRUSSES WELL.
ALL RIGHT. BETTER MODERATOR
LET'S DO A LAST CALL FOR THOSE
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY THREE
TWELVE. THANK YOU AND IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY THREE TWELVE. PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH LAYS INJURED
IN COMMITTEE WERE NOT GONNA BE
FOCUSING ON OR IN PERSON
SUPPORT IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE UNDERSTAND AND
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF PIC PLEASE
DO SO NOW. HEARING SEEN KNOWN
WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY LOOKING ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO AND
THEY'RE READY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY THREE
TWELVE. FOR TO GO BACK TO OUR
PHONE LINES LAYS IN GERMAN
WE'RE GONNA CHECKING TO SEE IF
WE HAVE OUR LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION A AND THAT MAY BE
MISS MILLER. IF MISS MILLER IS
ON THE LINE WE WEREN'T SURE
SHE'S GOING TO BE A JOIN US BUT
WE WANT TO GIVE HER AN
OPPORTUNITY MISS MILLER WITH
CAL LASKO. THAT MATTER
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE MISS
MILLER ON THE LINE. AND MISS
MILLER IF YOU WOULD PRESS. STAR
AND THEN ZERO. WE'LL BE ABLE TO
TAKE YOUR NAME. OKAY. MISS
MILLER YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON- PAM MILLER
REPRESENTING LASKO. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN CHOIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS PAMELA MILLER REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION
COMMISSION WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
THREE MINUTES MA'AM. THANK YOU-
I DO WANT TO CLARIFY THAT WHILE
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL IN
ITS CURRENT FORM- DATED JULY
WENTY THIRD. WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS ARE
THAT ARE BEING TAKEN BY THE
AUTHOR TODAY NOW WE ALSO WANT
TO SYNC ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY
AND HIS STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US. REGARDING OUR CONCERNS
ALSO- MISTER CHAIR YOU AND YOUR
STAFF- FOR THAT COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. SO THE SOONEST
THOSE AMENDMENTS ARE IN PRINT
WE WILL BE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION AGAIN WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE AFTER WORKING
WITH US TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SHOULD THAT'S
PAMELA MILLER FROM CAL LAUGHTER
WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE WITH
OUR TELEPHONE COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY THREE
TWELVE. THAT A MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE DO IN ALL CALL THOSE
WHO ARE OPPOSED AB THIRTY THREE
TWELVE NOW. THANK THANK YOU AND
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY THREE
TWELVE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION PRESS. ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. BETTER
MODERATOR HOW WE LOOKING IN THE
QUEUE. BUT WE DO HAVE ONE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON. CRAP AND THEN
THERE IS THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE IN MY NAME'S MICHAEL
CLAIBORNE I'M NOT TURNING WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. I AND I
JUST KNOW WE HAVEN'T SEEN-
MEDIUM AND YET THEY MAY IMPACT
OUR POSITION THAT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING- THESE
COMMENTS ARE BASED ON THE
VERSION THAT IN PRINT- WE
SUBMITTED A LETTER OPPOSING A.
B. THREE THIRTY THREE TWELVE. I
LET THEM AND ANSWER MADE-
LEADERS ACCOUNTABLE AS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS WITH
RESIDENTS IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY ON ISSUES INCLUDING AIR
QUALITY. LAND USE ACT THAT THE
SAFE AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
AND THE STATE QUICK WATER
SERVICE. IN MERCED COUNTY WE
WORK WITH RESIDENTS IN THE
COMMUNITIES OF DEL HIGH OUT
WATER BE TOWARD FRANKLIN. CITY
OF MERCED EMPANADA. OUR
SPECIFIC CONCERNS ON THE BILL
ARE ONE THAT THE CITY OF MERCED
HAS NOT FULFILLED ITS LEGAL OF
THE BLIGATION TO IDENTIFY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WITH
THAT. INFLUENCE ANALYZE SERVICE
DEFICIENCIES AND TAKES STEPS TO
RECTIFY SERVICE DEFICIENCIES.
AND TO THAT DRINKING WATER AND
WASTEWATER DEFICIENCIES WITHIN
THE SERVANT EMPLOYMENT SHOULD
BE ADDRESSED CRIER CLINIC
ANNEXATION OF THAT SIZE. THAT
THREATENS THE FURTHER WITHDRAW
RESOURCES FROM EXISTING
COMMUNITIES CLOSER TO THE URBAN
CORE. AS DISCUSSED IN THE STAFF
ANALYSIS THERE ARE AT LEAST
FORTY SEVEN DISADVANTAGED
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES AND
RESPECT COUNTY. SEVERAL OF THE
SOUTH ARE IN THE CITY OF MERCED
YOUR OF INFLUENCE AND LACK
ACCESS PUBLIC DRINKING WATER
AND WASTEWATER INFRASTRUCTURE.
DESPITE THESE EXISTING
DISPARITIES THE CITY IN MERCED
HAS NOT COMPLETED AN ANALYSIS
OF DOCUMENTS HERE INFLUENCE. OR
ANALYZE RELATED SERVICE
DEFICIENCIES AS REQUIRED BY SB
TWO FOUR FOUR- THAT'S TWENTY
ELEVEN- BEFORE GRANTING BUT
CITY AN EXCEPTION TO THE
GENERAL REQUIREMENT THAT AN
ANNEXATION MUST BE CONTIGUOUS
THE CITY. BOUNDARIES IT'S OUR
POSITION THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD REQUIRE THE CITY OF
MERCED TO COMPLY WITH ITS
OBLIGATION. TO DOCK AND IT'S AN
IMPORTANT BY. FIRST COMPLETING
AN AT THE TWO FORTY FOUR
ANALYSIS BY IDENTIFYING BACK IN
THE- INFLUENCE AND ANALYZING
SERVICE DEFICIENCIES. AND
SECOND TAKING STEPS TO BEGIN
ADDRESS THESE SERVICE
DEFICIENCIES FIVE PLANNING
EXTENSION OF WATER AND
WASTEWATER SERVICE. AND
SPEAKING OUT CONSTRUCTION
FUNDING TO COMPLETE THESE
PROJECTS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE OUT THERE IN
THE COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THAT AN
EXCEPTION THAT WOULD AUTHORIZE
THE PROPOSED ANNEXATION IS
PAIRED WITH ACTION THE BETTER
UNDERSTAND. ADDRESS THEN
ELIMINATE. THE STATE BY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AND
THE CITY OF MERCED. SHARE OF
INFLUENCE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE YOU SO MUCH PHYSICALLY BORN
WILL IS A CLAY. NIGHT TO BE TO
PROVIDE THOSE CALM SINCE WE TO
IN THE- WHO. UP THREE MEN AND
SOME WE'RE GONNA ALLOW TO BE A
TO PEAK IN OPPOSITION UP TO
THREE MINUTES WE'RE NOW GOING
TO BE GOING TO OPPOSITION WE'RE
JUST GOING TO ASK THE REMAINING
INDIVIDUALS ON THE LINE TO
PLEASE STATE THE FIRST AND LAST
NAME. AT THE ORGANIZATION IN A
POSITION ON THE BILL AND THAT A
MODERATOR LET'S GO TO
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION COMMENTS
PLEASE. IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION ON A. B. THIRTY
THREE TWELVE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE HAVE NO COMMENTS IN Q.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER
MODERATOR LAST CALL FOR
OPPOSITION PLEASE. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY THREE
TWELVE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH SAYS GOING TO
CONCLUDE OUR ITELEFONICA
OPPOSITION COMMENTS WERE NOT
GOING TO BE LOOKING TO THOSE
WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE. KAREN SEEN KNOWN WERE
NOT TO BE GOING TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WE'RE GONNA SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY KNOWN AS IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY TO THAT PROVIDE
OPPOSITION COMMENTS. WE'RE
GONNA TURN IT TO COMMITTEE WE
DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
BY- THE MAJORITY LEADER WE'RE
GONNA GO TO SENATOR NIELSEN THE
DEAN OF THE SENATE DEBATE OFFER
COMMENTS AND THEN WE'RE GONNA
GO TO THE VICE CHAIR CENTER
NIELSEN THE FORESHORES. MISTER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO
LEND MY INDICATION OF SUPPORT.
ALONG WITH THAT OF. CENTER
HERTZBERG. HAVING BEEN RAISED
IN THAT VALLEY HAS. BEEN
PRETTY. WELL ACQUAINTED. WITH
THE GROWING OF. RIVERSIDE
COUNTY THOSE. FOLLOW THE VALLEY
COUNTIES IN FACT. IT THE CHAO.
THAT THEY HAVE FACE. OVER THE
YEARS I'VE WORKED WITH STE NOW
SENATOR GALGIANI THAT SHE HAS
ADVOCATED FOR THE UNIVERSITY
THERE AND ASSEMBLYMAN GREAT.
AND ALSO VERY DIRECTLY THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT FRESNO STATE
UNIVERSITY JOE CASTRO SPENT A
NUMBER OF YEARS IN MERCED
WORKING TRYING TO WORK OUT ALL
THE DIFFICULTIES TO ENSURE THAT
THAT CAMPUS WOULD BE CITED. IT
IS NOW CITED IN I WILL INDEED
IT'S VERY CRITICAL I BELIEVE TO
THE GROWTH INTELLECTUAL GROWTH
ECONOMIC GROWTH OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THIS SEEMS LIKE A- AN
ITEM THAT NEEDS TO BE WORKED
OUT. AND THEY ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF ACHIEVING IT I THINK
WITH A LOT OF WORK ON BEHALF OF
THE AUTHOR I COMMEND THEM IN
OTHER THAN MY SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
NEAR SERVER TO GO TO THE VICE
CHAIR THEY WERE TO GO TO CENTER
ABOUT MISTER VICE CHAIR. THANK
MEASURE OF BEING SOMEONE WHO-
SERVED ON THE ORANGE COUNTY
LEFT- AND- DISSIPATED AND CAL
AFTER OVER ONE IT'S GOOD TO SEE
THAT CAL I'VE GOES. AT LEAST
PLAYING OFF OF THEIR OPPOSITION
BUT- BY MY BRIEFING TELLS ME
THAT TO DATE MERCED LEFT COKE
MERCED CITY COUNCIL MERCED
COUNTY. UC MERCED AND THE UC
MERCED CHANCELLOR HAVE HAVE
TAKEN NO POSITION ON THE BILL.
SO THAT HAS ME A LITTLE
CONFUSED SO MAYBE THE FIRST
QUESTION WOULD BE WHY. THE
CENTER I'M. FURTHER SOUTH AND
THEN TO COULD YOU JUST EXPLAIN
THE HISTORY OF WHY YOU NEEDED
TO GO THROUGH A LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTION AS OPPOSED TO A LOCAL
SOLUTION. NUMBER. THANK YOU A
CENTER FOR THE QUESTION WELL
THE FIRST AND FOREMOST CAN
OPPOSITION SPOTS THAT IS THE
COMPLICATIONS OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS RUBIO OF
CERTAINLY MADE IT MORE
DIFFICULT- IN ALL OF OUR ALL OF
HIS GOVERNMENT TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH SUPPORT LETTERS AND
ACTIVITIES THAT OTHERWISE ARE
FAIRLY NORMAL COURSE OF NORMAL
BUSINESS. THE HISTORY OF IT IS
WHAT I WAS GETTING IN MY
OPENING IS THAT THE OF THE
STATE MADE THIS DECISION
EFFECTIVE CAMPUS SEVEN MILES
ABOUT FOUR MILES OUTSIDE OF
TOWN SEVEN MILES FROM THE MOST
DEAD CENTER- PORTIONS OF TOWN.
AND THEY DID THAT BECAUSE THIS
LAND WAS DONATED BY THE-
BRITISH MISTRUST. AND BY CITING
THE LAND OUT THERE. COMBINED
WITH THE HOUSING CRISIS THAT WE
WENT INTO IN THE MID TWO
THOUSANDS THERE WAS- ESTIMATE
GROWTH TOWARDS THE CAMPUS NO
GROWTH COULD OCCUR AROUND THE
CAMPUS UNTIL THE CITY MEETS AS
I'M SURE YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH
HAVING SERVED- INTO LAUGHTER
POSITION. SO IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE- GROSS NOW TO CREATE
BOTH A CAMPUS LIFE AND ALSO
ADDRESS THE HOUSING ISSUE
BECAUSE ONE THING THAT WAS
TOUCHED ON BRIEF IN SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION COMMENTS IS KIND OF
THE FACT ON SOME THE OTHER
COMMUNITY SERVER SIDE. AMBER
SAID AS A 1% VACANCY RATE.
RIGHT THAT LIKE MANY PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA ALTHOUGH I THINK
PEOPLE OFTEN TIMES OVERLOOKED
US BECAUSE WERE RURAL- AND WERE
SMALL BUT WE'RE FACING THE SAME
HOUSING SHORTAGES IF NOT IN
SOME CASES WORST BECAUSE BEING
A COMMUNITY THAT'S WITHIN. YOU
KNOW A TWO TO TWO AND A HALF
HOUR DRIVE OF MOST PORTIONS THE
BAY AREA. LIVING IN THE BAY
AREA HAS BECOME SO
EXTRAORDINARILY EXPENSIVE FOR
MOST WORKING CALIFORNIANS AS
YOU KNOW THE TAPE. OUT INTO
MASTER LOS BANOS MERCED CAN
IMPACT OUR HOUSING CRISIS EVEN
WORSE. ON TOP OF THAT WE ADDED
TEN THOUSAND STUDENTS AS WELL
AS A SUPPORT STAFF AND FACULTY.
FOR THOSE TEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS. AND SO WE'RE REALLY
IN A BREAKING POINT ON HAVING
TO HAVE STUDENT HOUSING TO FREE
UP HOUSING FOR OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY. TO ALSO CREATE
SOME CAMPUS LIFE. IT HAS BEEN
DIFFICULT OVER THE LAST DECADE
TO EVEN RECRUIT. FACULTY TO THE
CAMPUS COULD YOU BRING FACULTY
THE CAMPUS YOU'VE GOT. A BACK
YOU KNOW SOME CAMPUS LIFE ON A
SMALLER FOOTPRINT BECAUSE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES. AND
NOTHING GOING ON AROUND IT
MAYBE MAYBE MORE FIVE MILES
AWAY REMEMBER GRAY MAYBE I
DIDN'T ASK THE QUESTION THAT I
AGO HAD RISEN I'M JUST KIND OF
CURIOUS WHY DIDN'T MERCED LAUGH
GO. THE TODAY HAVE HEARINGS
TODAY DO A- A GETTING READY TO
DO YOUR WILL COME HISTORY AS
WELL WHY IT JUST IT JUST SEEMS
LIKE A NO BRAINER THAT'S WHY.
I'M JUST MISSING THE NEED TO
COME HERE AS OPPOSED TO. LAUGH
GO IN THE BOARD APPROVING IT
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY IT'S
UNINCORPORATED AREA IN. A
RECEIPT THE CITY SHOULD BE THE
RIGHT. I MEAN I WORK REALLY
HARD TO ANNEX. UNINCORPORATED
AREAS IN THE CITY'S AYE WE
DON'T HAVE. RURAL AREA EIGHTY
MARCH KENNY BUT WE HAVE ALL
THESE LITTLE ISLANDS. SO I'M
I'M JUST MISSING THAT PART OF
THE STORY AND I APOLOGIZE THAT.
I JUST DIDN'T LAUGHTER DID
DISCUSS THE BILL THEY DIDN'T
TAKE A POSITION- SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE. AND I THINK THE ANSWER
TO SOME OF THE CITY IN THIS TO
BE MY FINAL POINT ON WHY WE ARE
WHERE WE'RE AT- IS THE POLITICS
OF CITY GOVERNMENT. LAUGH GO.
AHEAD. THAT ALL TOGETHER AND
SOMETIMES YOU GET INACTION.
WHICH IS PRECISELY WHY STEPPED
IN. AT THE STATE LEVEL SAID
WELL IT'S IN EVERYBODY'S
COLLECTIVE INTEREST TO HAVE THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
THE STATE INVESTMENT MADE BY.
OUR INSTITUTION. ANNEXED INTO
THE CITY THE GROWTH THAT OCCURS
THEN AROUND IT FOLLOWING THE
RULES AND PROCEDURES OF.
LAUGHTER AND LOCAL ORDINANCES-
WILL BE WHAT WHAT WILL BE AND
WE CAN WORK THROUGH THOSE
POLITICS BUT WE WORK. BASICALLY
HAMSTRUNG- IN MOVING FORWARD-
IS DIFFERENT YOU KNOW ENTITIES
HAD DIFFERENT OPINIONS FOR.
SOME POLICY AND PROBABLY SOME
POLITICAL REASONS RIGHT SO THIS
IS MY WAY OF SERVING- YOU KNOW
THE STATE'S INTEREST AS WELL AS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS INTERESTING
KIND OF. SPURRING THAT ACTIVITY
TO MOVE FORWARD. YOU'RE SHOWING
LEADERSHIP ON ON A MAJOR
CONCERN. SO WHAT I'M MISSING AT
ALL IN WITH THIS QUESTION. IS
AFTER THIS A PER ON THIS FLOOR
AND GOES TO THE GOV IS THE
GOVERNOR TO GET ALL A LETTER
AND MAY EVEN A THREAT OF LET.
FROM THE CITY OR FROM THE
UNIVERSITY AND SAYING THIS THIS
IS NOT THE RIGHT ANSWER AND
THEY JUST KIND OF. THOUGHT
MAYBE THE BILL WOULDN'T. GET
THIS FAR SIDE. I AM JUST
WONDERING ABOUT SOME KIND OF
SURPRISE AND I APOLOGIZE FOR.
ASKING IN THAT VEIN BUT AGAIN
IT IT SHOWS THAT I DON'T HAVE
ALL THE DATA I APPRECIATE THAT
SIR VERY DIRECT AND- WE GET IT.
I WOULDN'T ANTICIPATE ANY
LITIGATION I THINK THERE IS
BROAD BASED SUPPORT IN ALL OF
THOSE ENTITIES THAT YOU'VE
RAISED I THINK THE REASONS
PEOPLE HAVEN'T NECESSARILY STEP
FORWARD IN. FULL SUPPORT AT
THIS JUNCTURE BUT I DON'T THINK
I THINK EVERYONE SEES THIS IN
OUR COMMUNITY'S COLLECTIVE
INTEREST- I HAVE EVERY
CONFIDENCE THAT YOU WILL NOT
SEE THAT OCCUR. ON THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSUME MEMBER GRAY FOR A
LIVING ASK QUESTIONS PREACHING.
INTEREST THANK YOU AND BEFORE
WE GO TO CENTER. IN A GREAT
PLEASE PUT BACK AS I KNOW THIS
IS A AND YOU SHOULD YOU'VE BEEN.
STRUGGLING WITH FOR LONG HE
LAUGHED ALONG SPECIFICALLY
PROHIBITS ANY. TEAR THAT IS.
CONNECTED TO THIS BY A- WHICH
IS WHAT OF THE MAIN DRIVER A
DAY. WILD AS AN AUTHOR THE BILL
AUTHORIZED BUT NOT RE. WHICH IS
SO CRITICAL RIGHT TO BE A TO
GET THIS DONE IN NO THIS IS
BEEN A REAL HANG UP AS WELL AS
A MEMBER GREAT PLEASE FISH BACK
ON THE- FUNDING FOR. BUT I
THINK ONE OF THE MOST CRITICAL
OF THIS. SO THE. FRIEND A
FLEXIBLE GIVEN THE EXACT WE'RE
NOT AND YET ANYONE PROCEED IN
X. FORM BRIDGES OPENING A THE
OP AND JACK WORKED. WITH
COUNTIES AND LW TO ME SURE AND
I THINK ULTIMATELY THAT'S WE
GOT THE ASSOCIATE FROM ABOUT IS
THAT WE HAVE HAD THAT CLOSE
WORKING RELATIONSHIP ALL ROWING
IN THE SAME DIRECTION- AND
APPRECIATE YOU APPRECIATE YOU
POINT THAT OUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS A NUMBER THAT'S GOING
TO SENATOR ABOUT PLEASE THANK
YOU MUCH YOUR WORK ON THE
UNIVERSITY THERE I'M INTERESTED
IN THE TOWN DOWN. YOUR NATION
AND CAN YOU TALK ABOUT A LITTLE
BIT OF THE MAY PLAN FOR THE-
AND- THE PROCESS IS BEING USED
TO WORK. TO HAVE- THE CITY AND
THE UNIVERSITY WORK TOGETHER IN
TERMS OF PLANNING- YOU KNOW
THERE'S YOU KNOW HOW TO SAY
THIS THERE SOME. GOOD EXAMPLES-
COORDINATED PLANNING BETWEEN
THE TOWNS INNER VERSUS. AND
THEN THERE'S SOME NOT SO GOOD.
I LIVE IS STILL YOU KNOW. YOU
KNOW THERE'S SOME NOT SO GOOD
ONES. SO CAN YOU TALK ABOUT
THAT A LITTLE BIT. I'M GONNA
SPEND A LOT OF TIME THERE. IN
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS BY THE WAY
BECAUSE OF MY- INCOMING
FRESHMEN NEPHEW IS GONNA COME
INTO USING WERE SET UP WITH.
THE WATCH IT AS A HALF SO I TO
WHY ONE TO FIND OUT ABOUT THE
TOWN DOWN CONNECTION I THOUGHT
THE UC SANTA CRUZ TO PRETTY
GOOD JOB WITH CITIES CRUZ. ISLA
VISTA ACCORD WE DON'T LIKE THAT
THERE'S OTHER EXAMPLES SO COULD
YOU ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. IF
SOMEONE THIS AFFECT THAT. THANK
YOU SIR. WELL BEGIN BY SAYING A
AS A GALA IN THE SEE AS WE GROW
AND A FORMER OF VISTA I'M NOT
SURE I TOTALLY CAN WITH YOUR
BUT I'M ON A PAIR LOOK OUT SO.
BUT CERTAIN UNDERSTAND THE
POINT AND AN THERE ARE GROW
PAINS. WANT TO WHEN HAVE DOWN
THERE. BUT THERE'S GROWING
PAINS IN THESE LIKE YOUR STORE.
USE HUMOR AND THIS IS PERCENT
CASH HAVE HAVE HAD A- 9%
PRODUCTOR. POSITIVE
RELATIONSHIP I I'VE MET WITH
THE CAL. FOR ON THIS BILL THE
GOALS AND MOTIVATIONS AND I
KNOW THEY ARE 1% AND THAT WE
NEED THAT AND STUDENT HOW OR
THE CAMP. BOTH TO HOW RECRUIT
FACULTY GOING FOR MANY OF THE
FIVE AT. UC MERCED TEACHING
THERE RIGHT NOW. IN THE BAY
AREA. AND COMMUTE TO TEACH
COURSES AND DOES OF US THAT ARE
LIFELONG RESIDENTS OF SIDE LIKE
MYSELF TO BUILD. THIS TO BEING.
OF THOSE IN THE WERE AT THE
HAVE THEM BE PART THE FAB. OF
OUR CAN BE IT ALSO ECONOMIC
ENGINE RIGHT YOU SEE MERCED HAS
BEEN A LYFT FOR. A COMMUNITY
THAT WAS DE IN THE EARLY-
NINETEEN NINETIES WHEN WE LOST
CASTLE AIR FORCE BASES I KNOW
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH WHERE IS
HAVING SOME FAMILY MEMBERS
THERE WERE EXCITED TO HAVE YOUR
NEPHEW- JOIN US- IN MERCED. BUT
I THINK THIS APPROACH WE'RE
TAKING THIS BILL. THAT AGAIN
DOES NOT DIRECT OR FORCE ANY
PARTICULAR CONSTRUCT BUT RATHER
GIVE SOME FLEXIBILITY TO THE
COUNTY TO LAUGH TO THE
UNIVERSITY TO CITY TO HERE OF
COURSE THERE IS A EVERY BEST. I
AUTUMN IS GOING TO. KIND OF A
MODEL. BUT MERCED IN THE IN AND
I IN SOME RESPECTS SHE MERCED
AND KNOW YOU'VE BEEN DOWN THERE.
HAS ASKED THE MA FOR WHAT BILL
UNIT IS LOOK LIKE GOING IN THIS
OF DOES OF OUR SAID AND DO. ON
A- COOPERATIVE PLANNING AS THE
THROUGH THE I THINK IT'S GONNA
BE VERY AND THAT THE- BEST SOME
STRUCK FOR THE MAYBE JOINT TO
YEARS KIND OF. WAY THAT THE CAN.
WORK TOGETHER A NAME. AS THEY
GO THROUGH THE PROCESS THANK
YOU. AND NOT SUPPORT OUR
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY WHAT ONE
LAST POINT I WOULD IS YOU KNOW
THE- INVEST OF THE CAMPUS PER.
WHICH YOU'RE WELL FOR BYE WITH.
RIGHT YOUR CAPACITIES CHAIRMAN
TATIAN HAS BEEN A MAJOR PART OF
SETTING THE COM OF WHAT THAT
CAN USE LOOK LIKE WELL THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- YOU KNOW YOU WANT.
YOU COULD BRO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER.
A BEFORE WE THE VOTE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE IF THERE IS. ELSE FROM
COMMIT WHO HAVE ANY. OR HAVEN'T
SEEN NINE LAY INJENICA WE DO
HAVE A- WE HAVE. A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR BY MAJORITY LEADER
HURTS FOR THIS IS A TO PASS IT
IS AN TO FLOOR WE'RE GOING TO
TURN OVER TO GOODNESS IN THE
FOR CLOSING PLEASE. BUT THEY
YOU FOR THE LIVELY DEBATE AND
THE ENTRY IN WHAT I THINK IS
EXTERNAL IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR MY
WHOLE. AND THE LARGER. IN
STOPPED ABOUT AN IRISH. ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ENGAGEMENT A MEMBER OF
MISTER ROLL CALL PLEASE.
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI WIRE HI. MY
LOCK. BY MORAL. HI. IS A FIVE
ZERO VOTE FOR TO KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN AND ALLOW SENT HER TITLE
AS WELL AS HERTZBERG TO BE AN
ADD ON SOME NUMBER THANK YOU.
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL THANKS FOR
YOUR TIME SIR. ALL RIGHT PLEASE
IN GERMAN WE HAVE- OUR FINAL
AUTHOR OF THE DAY AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CINNAMON FOR
HIS WORK ON THIS LOOK AT ANY
TIME YOU ARE DEALING WITH OPEN
MEETING LAW IT IS NOT EASY HE
IS BEEN ENGAGE ON THIS BILL
HE'S BEEN OPEN TO CHANGES AND I
JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO THE
SOME WOMEN FOR ALL THIS HARD
WORK TRULY- NO B. S. ON THAT AT
MISTER SOMEONE MEMBER WE'RE
GRATEFUL YOU WERE GOING TO TURN
THE FLOOR OVER FOR YOU TO
PRISON AB NINE NINE TO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE KIND WORDS
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT- AND YOUR STAFF'S
ENGAGEMENT- ON THE ISSUE AS
WELL- FOR SOME INDICATE THAT. I
DO INDEED ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS NOTED AND
COMMENT FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS AB
NINE NINE TO SIMPLY CLARIFIES
THE MEMBERS OF LOCAL ELECTED
BODIES MAY NGAGE ON SOCIAL
MEDIA PROVIDED THEY DO NOT
INTERACT IN ANY WAY THAT
VIOLATES THE BROWN ACT FOR
SPECIFIC AB NINE NINE TWO
ALLOWS MEMBERS TO USE SOCIAL
MEDIA PROVIDED THAT A MAJORITY
OF THE MEMBERS DO NOT DISCUSS
AMONG THEMSELVES BUSINESS UP
THE SPECIFIC NATURE. IS WITHIN
THE SUBJECT MATTER JURISDICTION
OF THE LEGISLATIVE BODY OF THE
LOCAL AGENCY WITH EVOLVING
FORMS OF COMMUNICATION OF
PARTICIPATION SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS LOCAL OFFICIALS ARE
INDICATED TO ME THAT IT IS
UNCLEAR WHAT IS ALLOWED WHEN
INTERACTING WITH THE PUBLIC ON
SOCIAL MEDIA SOMETHING NOT
CONSIDERED WHEN THE BROWN ACT
WAS FIRST ENACTED IN NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE THE DEMOCRATIZING
ASPECT OF SOCIAL MEDIA IS THAT
IT GIVES CITIZENS NEARLY FULL
ACCESS TO THE BACK TO THE FISH
BOWLS PRIOR TO THE ADVENT OF
SOCIAL MEDIA CONSTITUENTS ALL
THE ACCESS WAS TO MAKE
APPOINTMENTS IS ELECTED. HAPPEN
TO RUN INTO THEM OUT ABOUT- TEN
COUNSEL THIS BILL THIS NOT IN
COURAGE ALLOW. OF TO DELIVER.
WITHOUT NOTICE ON SOCIAL MEDIA
BUT INSTEAD PROVIDE STRUCTURING
CLARITY TO INTERACTIONS THAT
ARE MOST LIKELY ALREADY
HAPPENING. ONLINE ESSENTIALLY
WE ARE BRINGING THE BROWN ACT-
INTO THE SOCIAL MEDIA ERA. TO
EXCLUDE SOCIAL MEDIA-
PARTICIPATION HARM CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND DOES A
DISSERVICE TO THE PUBLIC. FALL
UNDERMINING TRANSPARENCY IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT WITH YOU
MA'AM AND SUGGESTED IN THE
ANALYSIS. THERE'S NO LONGER ANY
OPPOSITION TO AB NINE AND TWO I
AM GRATEFUL FOR THE WORK PUT IN
BY THIS- COMMITTEE STAFF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT REPS AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA NEWSPAPER.
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION WITH ME
TODAY ARE REPRESENTATIVES OF
LEAVING CALIFORNIA CITIES THE
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
AND THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS A MEMBER AGAIN JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SINCERE ENGAGEMENT YOUR STAFF
SINCE YOUR ENGAGEMENT TO BE TO
WORK THROUGH THIS- THIS IS NOT
A SIMPLE ISSUE THAT YOU'VE
TAKEN ON AND VERY GRATEFUL AND
I THINK THE MUCH NEEDED. A
MODERNIZATION OF WHAT IS
IMPORTANT LAW IN THIS STATE.
ALRIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WE'RE GONNA GO TO OUR- LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESS WE HAVE ONE
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS ON FILE.
SB JOHN MERRY ARE HE IS A
LEGISLATIVE REPRESENTATIVE FROM
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES. MADAM MODERATOR IF YOU.
CAN PLEASE QUEUE UP BE SURE.
FROM CAL THE CITY. WILL HAVE
MINUTES MATTER MODERATOR. THANK
YOU HAS MINOR OPEN. THE GOOD
AFTERNOON SIR YOU'RE MINUTES
THE FLORA YOURS LIVE IN
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- JUST VERY
BRIEFLY WHAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM
OUR MEMBERSHIP IS THAT THE
EXISTING LAWS AMBIGUOUS MAKING
IT UNCLEAR HOW COUNCIL MEMBERS
CAN INTERACT WITH THEIR
CONSTITUENTS ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
WE THINK THAT THE BAND ACUITY
UNDER THE DISSEMINATION OF
INFORMATION ON WHAT IS BECOMING
UBIQUITOUS PLATFORMS THE PUBLIC
DISCOURSE. WE THINK THAT EIGHTY
NINE NINETY TWO ADDRESSES THAT
AMBIGUITY BY DRAWING A CLEAR
LINE BETWEEN WHAT CONDUCT IS
AND IS NOT PERMISSIBLE. WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE COLLABORATIVE
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT THE OTHER KEY
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE AUTHORS
OFFICE FOR GETTING THE MEASURE
TO THIS POINT I'M HAPPY TO HELP
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
HE JOHN THANKS SO MUCH COULD
HEAR VOICE SIR WE'RE NOW GOING
TO BE GOING TO. WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE NINE. BETTER
ROOM MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE Q. OF THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE NINE TWO.
THANK YOU AND IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
NINE NINE TO. PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE THREE ONE
I'M SORRY A. B. NINE NINE TWO.
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND OUR FIRST COMMENT
COMES FROM MINE FIFTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON. THE TEACHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE DILLON
GIVENS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION-
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF HIS-
NEEDED UPDATE TO THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT ELECTED SINK
TO CHEER FOR ANOTHER WELL RUN
COMMITTEE APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
EFFORTS THANK YOU I THINK SO
MUCH WAS GIVEN COULD HEAR YOUR
VOICE SIR LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING YOU SOON LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE MATTER
MODERATOR. EIGHT EIGHT. OUR
NEXT LINE IS MINE THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU THIS IS JEFF
MEAL AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. ALSO
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS
INYO GOOD TO HEAR YEAH LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE MADAM
MODERATOR. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN CUTE IN FAVOR OF AB
NINE NINE TWO. AND A MODERATOR
IN THE TATE AND LAST THE LAST
CALL FOR EIGHTY NINE NINE TWO
IN SUPPORT LAST CALL IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINE NINE TWO MATTER
MODERATOR. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINE NINE TO PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH SHE LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
WITH THOSE WHO MAY BE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE'RE GOING
TO CHECK IN HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. SEEN IF THERE'S
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL HEARING
SEEN NO ONE WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY FROM
TWENTY FORTY SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE NINE TO.
NOTHING WE GOT NOTHING IN A
ROOM TWENTY A FORTY. LAYS IN
GERMAN WERE NOT GOING TO GO TO
LIVE LINE IN CHECK IN WITH OUR
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS. THAT'S
GOING TO BE JIM EVERT HE'S A
GENERAL COUNSEL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION. MATTER MODERATOR
LET'S SEE IF WE HAVE MISTER YOU
WERE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE. AND
MR EBERT IS IN THE IS ON AND
THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
YOU WERE YOU WERE ALIVE AND
COMMITTEE YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES SIR THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
YESTERDAY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO ME WORK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION. I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN AND HIS
STAFF- AS WELL AS YOUR STAFF
FOR. HELPING NAVIGATE THROUGH-
THIS VERY DIFFICULT- ISSUE AND
WHEN WE FIRST SAW THIS BILL- WE
WERE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS TO WHAT WE CONSIDER
TO BE. ONE OF THE HALLMARKS
PROVISIONS OF THE BROWN ACT
THAT PREVENTS. LOCAL AGENCIES
FROM MEETING- IN SECRET AND
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
USE OF SOCIAL MEDIA. TO
CIRCUMVENT THAT IMPORTANT
PROTECTION IN THE LAW- I THINK
WHAT WE'VE WHERE WE'VE GOTTEN
TO WITH THE- THE HELP OF- YOUR
STAFFING AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN STAFF. IS A PLACE WITH
THESE AMENDMENTS THAT- IF THEY
GO INTO THE BILL WILL HELP
ALLAY SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS-
WE LIKE THE IDEA THAT A SUNSET
PROVISION IS PART OF THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS. SO THAT WE
CAN EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE CHANGES TO THE LAW. CAN
MAKE ANY ADJUSTMENTS AS
NECESSARY GOING FORWARD- I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE LEADER
CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR- IT'S
EFFORT IN HELPING THE- WORK
WITH US ON OUR CONCERNS. AND I
ONCE THAT LANGUAGE- THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS PROPOSED GOES INTO
PRINT. AT THAT TIME WE WILL
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH TO SEE WORD THAT SAID JIM
YOU WERE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NEWS PUBLISHERS TO SO. LADIES
AND CHAIRMAN OF THE STATE ON
OUR TELEPHONE LINES RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY NINE NINE TWO. MATTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP THE OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY
NINE NINE TWO NOW. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH COMMENT ON OPPOSITION
OF AB NINE NINE TO PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT HOW WE LOOKING AT A
MODERATOR. AND ONE MOMENT. BOOK
SOMETHING WITH A DOG READY TO
TALK. WE DO OF EVERY JUST A
BRIEF MOMENT OF WHAT WE'RE
GATHERING THE LINE NUMBER THANK
YOU AND. ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON. WE'RE GONNA
CHECK IN WITH LINE TWENTY EIGHT
GOOD AFTERNOON LINE TWENTY
EIGHT YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE.
ADELINE TWENTY EIGHT AND YOUR
SENATOR MCGUIRE HOW YOU DOING
WELCOME. IT WORKED IT DIDN'T
WORK THIS MORNING WITH YOUR
COLLEAGUE CONNIE LEIVA SO MAYBE
THAT'S M GOLDEN. TIDBIT FOR
TODAY I AM HI FOR MY GOVERNMENT
AND IN THAT SAME I'M JUST
CALLING VOICE OPPOSITE TO B.
NINE TWO. THANK YOU SO MUCH I
HAVE A MOMENT OF YOUR TIME. TO
SPEAK MY CONCERNS. I'M SORRY
MA'AM RIGHT NOW WHAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR ARE THOSE WE HAD A
LEAD WITNESS IN SUPPORT WHO HAD
THREE MINUTES LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- WILL WHO WAS AT THE
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION SO WHAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR AN HOUR THOSE WHO
WERE IN OPPOSITION. FIRST AND
LAST NAME ME ORGANIZATION IF
YOU HAVE ONE IN YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL. THAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO BE A STATE YOUR NAME
FOR THE RECORD MA'AM. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. HELLO HELLO
MA'AM THIS IS- YOU'RE BACKING
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE WHAT I
WAS JUST ASKING IS IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE YOUR
NAME IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL.
MY NAME IS ANDREA HEADS FROM I
USED TO LIVE IN YOUR DISTRICT
BEFORE. ALL RIGHT MISS HITS
ROOM WE APOLOGIZE THAT WE THINK
THE LINE MAY JUST CRIED OUT
BUT- WE ARE GOING TO REGISTER
MISS HEADS ROOMS OPPOSITION TO
A. B. NINE NINE TWO AND WE
APOLOGIZE A- SHE JUST GOT CUT
OFF THEIR- THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR CALLING MISS HEADS FROM.
AMANDA MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO
ASK IF THERE IS ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE NINE TWO.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB NINE NINE TO PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO FOR FURTHER COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE NINE TWO.
MINIMUM WRITER IF WE CAN DO A
LAST CALL PLEASE OPPOSITION
LAST CALL OPPOSITION EIGHTY
NINE NINE TWO. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF AB
NINE NINE TO PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH BETTER MODERATE APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK TODAY WE'RE NOTGOING
TO BE LOOKING HEARING ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE TODAY TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION THE
BILL. AND SEE NO ONE WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THERE IS NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION WE'RE NOT
GOING TO TURN IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO BE TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MISTER VICE
CHAIR. I WOULD LIKE TO BE A
POLICE OFFICER VICE CHAIR TO
THE SIMMONS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- JUST LIKE YOURSELF AND-
SENATOR BELL WE- SERVED ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND- I'M
TRYING TO. RECALL WHEN WE DID
HAVE SOMEONE THAT. CLAIM THAT
WE VIOLATED THE BROWN ACTED IT
WAS USUALLY BY SOMEONE WHO
WITHIN FILE. SOME KIND OF
LAWSUIT THAT WITH VIOLATED IN
THAT MAYBE THE REMEDY WOULD BE
THAT WE- TAKE A SEMINAR FOR A
QUICK COURSE OR SOMETHING OF
THAT NATURE BUT IT DIDN'T
HAPPEN VERY OFTEN SO I'M-
TRYING TO. THINK ABOUT WHAT I
RAN INTO BUT IN IN IN THE-
BRIEFING THAT I HAVE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER A MALL AND I
DON'T HAVE ANY EXAMPLES LIKE
THAT WERE SOMEONE. WHILE THE A
I WAS STATING THAT YOU VIOLATED
THE BROWN ACT BECAUSE YOU USED
FACEBOOK OR YOU USE TWITTER OR-
AND SO ARM I WAS JUST CURIOUS.
IF YOU COULD GIVE ME. THE
HISTORY OF WHAT MOTIVATED YOU
TO DO THIS WHAT WHAT WHAT
TRANSPIRED THAT. CAN I GET A
GAVE ME THE INSPIRATION TO OUR
TO DO THE LEGISLATION WELL I
WAS ACTUALLY CONTACTED BY A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT LOCAL
OFFICIALS IN MY COUNTY. WHO
SAID YOU KNOW WE USE SOCIAL
MEDIA ALL THE TIME BUT THERE
REALLY IS VERY LITTLE GUIDANCE
ON HOW. WE CAN BE OPERATING-
WITHIN THE CONFINES OF THE
BROWN ACT- BUT IN THE SOCIAL
MEDIA CONTACTS IN FACT ONE OF
THE LOCAL OFFICIALS HAVE HAPPEN
TO WORK FOR FACEBOOK. AND WAS
ACUTELY AWARE OF SORT OF THE
LACK OF CLARITY AND WE'VE HEARD
OF MULTIPLE EXAMPLES IN THE
LEAGUE MAY WANT TO OPINE ON
THIS BUT- DEPENDING ON THE
NATURE OF YOUR CITY ATTORNEY
AND THEIR- LEVEL OF COMFORT
WITH SOCIAL MEDIA. THERE IS
VARYING ADVICE BEING GIVEN TO
LOCAL ELECTED ACROSS THE STATE
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF CLARITY
WITH WITH THE BROWN ACT AND
SOME OF ITS I DON'T WANT TO SIT
IN EQUITY PROVISIONS BECAUSE I
THINK THE BROWN ACT AS A FIVE.
PIECE OF CALIFORNIA LAW WHICH
IS WHY MAKE SURE WERE MY- IT
BRINGING IN TWO THE SO MEDIA
ERA AND REALLY BRINGING OUT
SOME OF THE FRANKLY REP
RESTRICTIONS INTO THIS CURRENT-
ERA WE HAVE WITHOUT A
RESTRICTING CONSTITUENT TO
ELECTED COMMUNICATIONS WHICH-
IS ABSOLUTELY VITAL. AND WE
KNOW THAT- I CAN SPEAK PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AS A FORMER- LOCAL
ELECTED THAT. THESE ARE BEING
READILY USED ESPECIALLY NOW
WITH- DURING THIS COBIT ERA
WHERE TECHNOLOGIES BEING
EMPLOYED BY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS UP ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- THIS IS GOING TO
BE I THINK A RICH AREA OF LAW
MOVING FORWARD. BUT THIS IS A
GOOD FIRST STEP- FOR THE FOR
THE SOCIAL MEDIA HI ERIN GIVE A
LITTLE MORE GUIDANCE FOR LOCAL
ELECTIVES HAS ANYONE FILED ANY
GRIEVANCES WITH THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION
THE F. PPC THAT. YOU'RE ALSO
TRYING TO. RESEARCH TO BY
SAYING BOY THAT WAS A RULING
THAT JUST DIDN'T SEEM TO FIT IN
WHAT'S GOING ON REALITY. SO A-
SENATOR IF YOU CAN JUST FIRST%
PART OF YOUR- APPLE WHAT WE
HAVE THE PPC AND I'M WONDERING
WAS ANYONE. ANYONE READ IT
RECEIVE A LETTER SAYING BOY YOU
YOU THE THREE OF YOU IF YOU
FIVE WORKED ON. YOU KNOW SOCIAL
MEDIA TOGETHER AND THEREFORE
WE'RE WE'RE SENDING YOU A
WARNING LETTER OR WERE ASKING
YOU TO CSS I DON'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC EXAMPLE- I. COULD TURN
TO OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
RAP TO SEE IF THEY'RE AWARE OF-
ANY PENDING. KINDS OF SUITS ARE
NO THERE'S DEFINITELY AN
INTERPRETIVE ELEMENT HERE WITH
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS. I IN TERMS
OF WHETHER OR NOT- THERE'S A
PROSPECTIVE BRIDE ACT VIOLATION
BUT THIS IS VERY MUCH- OF A
VACANT AREA OF LAW FRANKLY IN
THIS SOCIAL MEDIA- AND THAT WAS
THE INTENT BEHIND THE BILL BUT
I DON'T KNOW IF UP. OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
WANTS TO SPEAK TO THAT. ALL
RIGHTS OF A QUESTION ISN'T
EVERYTHING Q. WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO IS WE'RE WORKING WITH AN
AMAZING INDIVIDUAL HER NAME IS
PATTY HERE IN THE ROOM. HE'S
GOING TO WORK WITH UR
MODERATOR TO BE ABLE TO SEE IF
WE STILL HAVE. BE JOHN MERRY
ARE- ON FROM THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES. META
MODERATOR DO WE STILL HAVE BE
JOHN MERRY ARE ON FROM THE
LEAKY CALIFORNIA CITIES. THE
LINE IS OPEN ALL RIGHT AT
BEYOND GOOD AFTERNOON YOU'RE
BACK IN COMMITTEE THIS IS
MCGUIRE. WE HAVE A QUESTION
FROM THE VICE CHAIR VICE CHAIR
MORLOCK MISTER MOORLACH GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU ARE
JUST JUST CURIOUS- MISSED MARIE
ARE. YOU AVE THERE BEEN ANY
VIOLATIONS THAT WERE REMAIN
BEING OR HAS THE F. PPC ISSUED
ANY. OPPOSITION PAPERS OR OR-
ISSUE THE LETTERS TO ANY OF
YOUR MEMBERS SAYING YOU KNOW
YOU GET THREE OF THE FIVE CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS- VIOLATED. THIS
SECTION OF THE BROWN ACT.
THIRTY TO THE BEST OF MY
KNOWLEDGE RIGHT NOW I DON'T
HAVE THAT INFORMATION IN TERMS
OF WHETHER THERE BEEN LAWSUIT-
LEVIED AGAINST- COUNCILMEMBERS
VIOLATION BUT BROWN ACTOR
WHETHER THERE'S OR WHETHER
THERE ARE COMPLAINTS LARGE WITH
THE F. T. P. C. I THINK AB
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MALL AND SPOKE
TO THE CRUX OF THE ISSUE AND
PROP THE REASON WHY. WE DON'T
SEE THOSE ARE THOSE ARE THE
TYPES OF ENFORCING ACTIONS
AREN'T. HAPPENING IS BECAUSE
THERE IS NEEDED BY THE COUNCIL
MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE FROM
THE CITY ATTORNEY'S ARE
RECEIVING IS SO DIFFERENT ABOUT
THE DEGREE TO WHICH THEY MAY
INTERACT. WITH THE PUBLIC.
THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA THAT THAT
WOULD WORK WOULD BE TO REMEDY
THE LEGISLATION IT IS NOTSO
MUCH THAT THERE ARE. LAWSUIT
THAT HAVE BEEN INITIATED
BECAUSE THE UNIT BURDEN ACTION
BY COUNCILMEMBER BUT RATHER
WORK TRYING TO BE A LITTLE BIT
AT THE WHITE GUIDANCE. BUT IT
BUT PROPRIA COUNCILMEMBER NAPA
DIRECT INTERACTION WITH THEIR-
SITUATION. EVEN IF EIGHTY NINE
NINETY WERE TO BECOME LAW. THE
LIBERATION COMPONENT BETWEEN
COUNCIL MEMBERS WOULD STILL BE
ILLEGAL AND WOULD STILL BE A
BROWN ACT VIOLATIONS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO- WORK FOR. IS THAT
THERE ARE CLEAR GUIDANCE. ABOUT
HOW COUNCIL MEMBER. WITH THEIR
KEY IF YOU. NOW AMONG THEM.
BECAUSE THAT WOULD GO AT THE O
THE PROBE IN THE ACT ON
DELIBERATION BETWEEN
COUNCILMEMBER IF THAT MAKES
SENSE AND THAT ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION I APPRECIATE IT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MALL AND FOR
ALLOWING ME TO ASK. SOME OF
THAT THE BACKGROUND IF THE
NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS ARE
GETTING COMFORTABLE AND THAT
HELPS ME A LOT SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR BILL IN YOUR TIME THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE APPRECIATE THAT WE
PRESSURES MERRY ARE AS WELL.
THE CENTRE BELL POLICE YOU HAVE
THE FLOOR. THIS CENTER BILL HAS
A MOTION TO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS IS AMENDED TO THE FLOOR.
CENTRE BELL AS THAT MOTION TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE FLOOR.
DO YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
HEARING SEE NINE BEFORE I TURN
IT BACK TO THE SOME WOMEN TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE HIS CLOSING
COMMENTS I THINK THAT. THIS
THIS BILL. AGAIN I THINK THAT
EVERY LAW THAT WE HAVE. NEEDS
TO BE LIVE IN ANNE'S BE
BREATHING. CAN WE TAKE A LOOK
AT THE BROWN ACTING HOW
IMPORTANT IS- LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS CRITICAL TO BE TO MOVE
FORWARD. IN JUST A COUPLE OF
ITEMS I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
WE- ARE GRATEFUL TO BE WORKING
WITH THE SAME NUMBER ON- SO. WE
NOW ARE GOING TO SEE RULES
APPLYING TO CHAT ROOMS. AND
OTHER FORMS OF THE PLATFORMS
AND COMES A SOCIAL MEDIA WHICH
IS CRITICAL RIGHT- WHO WOULD
HAVE THOUGHT FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
THAT WE'D BE DOING THIS BUT
AGAIN. THROUGH THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS LEADERSHIP.
THAT WERE HERE TODAY BE TO LOOK
AT THIS UPDATE. IN A AGAIN. NO
ONE WOULD'VE THOUGHT PROBABLY
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO THAT. DIGITAL
ICONS LIKE A THUMBS UP. COULD
MEAN THAT I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
A BILL IN IT GOES TO TWO OTHER.
COUNCIL MEMBERS OR- TO. THREE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND IT'S A
QUORUM OF WHEN IT COMES A FIVE.
AGAIN TO THIS A MEMBERS
LEADERSHIP. I THINK THIS IS. A
CRITICAL THAT WE MOVE FORWARD
TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC RIGHT. AND TO BE ABLE TO
BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT TO EXPECT
WHEN IT COMES THE BRANIK SELF.
PLAN TURN OVER USE A MEMBER AND
AGAIN AS I SAY SINCERELY.
THANKS FOR WORKING WITH US IN
THIS TRUNCATED- ENVIRONMENT
THAT WE'RE ALL IN AND YOU HAVE
CLOSING COMMENTS. BUT A NOTE OF
THANKS TO YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
YOUR STAFF FOR THE ENGAGEMENT-
IN MY- MY SUSPICION IS THAT. WE
WILL HAVE TO COME BACK TO THIS
ISSUE. IN THE FUTURE AS TECH.
EVOLVES AND OTHER WAYS OF
COMMUNICATION- THAT WE CAN'T
EVEN ENVISION RIGHT NOW. ARE
HAPPENING- BUT THIS IS A GOOD
FIRST STEP TO. TO DEAL WITH A
AN AREA OF LAW THAT NEEDS-
MODERNIZING AND WITH THAT I
RESPECT RATIONALE VOTE. SUMMARY
THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS IS A MINUTE
OF FLORIDA MOTIONS BY SENATOR
BAIL. MISTER NOW ROLL CALL
PLEASE. SENATOR REQUIRE HIGH
WIRE HI SENATOR MORLOCK.
BARLACH FIVE SENATOR BILL. BILL
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
D'AMATO HI RICARDO HI SENATOR
NIELSEN. SENATOR WIENER. ARE
THERE IS CURRENTLY A FOUR ZERO
CURRENT I'M FOUR ZERO VOTE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TO KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN AND HAVE MEMBERS
COME BACK LAYS IN GENERAL
COMMITTEE GIVES TWO MINUTES
WE'RE GONNA COMPILER PAPERWORK
WE'RE GOING TO ADD FOLKS WHO
MAY NEED TO ADD ON HERE NOW
SERGEANTS ARE GOING TO BE
HUNTING DOWN TO INDIVIDUALS
THAT'S THE MAJORITY LEADER AND
SENATOR WIENER WE'RE GOING TO
BE ON THE HUNT TO BE TO GET
THEM TO ADD ON TO THE VOTES
GIVE US A COUPLE MINUTES WILL
BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU HERE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE.
ALRIGHT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE
GOING TO ADD CENTER HER TITLE
ON THE THREE ITEMS. SO FIRST
AND FOREMOST WE'RE GONNA GO TO
CONSENT AND THEN WE'RE GONNA
OPEN U THE CONSENT CALENDAR
BERGEN ASSN HER TITLE AT ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THEN WE'RE
GONNA GO TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE-
WHICH WE'RE GOING TO ADD TENER
TITLE ON A NUMBER FIVE AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA GO TO ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE WHICH WE MOVED UP TO
ITEM SIX- WHICH IS THE QUIRK
BILL- AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
ONCE WE THREE ITEMS ARE GONNA
GET HER TITLE ON HERE SHORTLY
ALL RIGHT SO LET'S DO IT. MR
PERSONALITY CAN PLEASE OPEN UP
THE CONSENT COUNTER CULTURAL
SENATOR HURTADO HI RICARDO.
SEVEN ZERO ALL RGHT THAT IS-
FULL HOUSE SEVEN ZERO THE CAN
SEE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT
RECALLS IN THE ROLE. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SOONER WE ARE
WORKING AND YOU ON MOMENTARILY-
SO WE'RE GONNA GO TO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AND NUMBER FIVE IS
AB THIRTY THREE TWELVE- PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS MR
GONNA. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR D'AMATO I. RICARDO HI
SIX ZERO KERN VOTE COUNTY SIX
YEAR OVER TO KEEP THAT ROLE
OPEN FOR SENATOR HERTZBERG WE
HAVE ONE MORE WHICH IS- FOR
CENTER TITLE WHICH IS AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY ONE. A IF YOU CAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MISTER
NOW. SENATOR HER TADO HI
RICARDO HI. SEVEN ZERO SEVEN
ZERO THAT BILL IS THAT WERE
CLOSE THE ROLEON AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY ONE. ALRIGHT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE GOING TO
JUMP BACK NOW- SO CENTER TITLE
YOU ARE GOOD TO GO THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER TARA. WE ARE NOW
GOING TO. GO TO TWO ITEMS FOR
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM SAN
FRANCISCO THE FIRST ITEM IS A.
B. NINE NINE TWO AB NINE NINE
TWO THAT'S A DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE FLOOR. AT THE CENTER
MELONES BILL MISTER NOW PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR NIELSEN.
SENATOR WIENER WIENER HI. FIVE
ZERO CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE
ZERO VOTE FOR KEEPING THAT ROLE
OPEN GIVEN THE ROLE OPEN FIVE
ZERO HI TO LASSEN HERTZBERG TO
JOIN AND WE'RE NOT GONNA MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO ITEM
NUMBER TWO IS AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN. THIS IS MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN I
APOLOGIZE ABSOLUTELY IT IS AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND WIENER PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. SENATOR WINNER.
WIENER FIVE SEVEN ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT ON A SEVEN ZERO VOTE
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLL CENTER
WIENER YOU'RE GOOD TO GO SIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS JOB.
DEALERS OUR LAYS IN GERMAN
WE'RE GOING TO COME BACK
TOGETHER BUT WE'RE GOING TO
DEAL WITH TWO BILLS TO BE ABLE
TO ADD- THE MAJORITY LEADER ON
TO THAT'S ITEM NUMBER. ONE
EIGHTY NINE NINE TWO. IN THEN
IT'S ALSO ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
THIRTY THREE TWELVE UP BY. SOME
NUMBER GREAT SO LET'S START
WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE- ONE WHICH
IS- MISTER MALL IN THIS IS A DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE FLOOR.
MR NOW CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ESTIMATES. SENATOR HERTZBERG BY
BERG HI. SIX TO ZERO MASON
GENERAL COMMITTEE THAT BILL IS
OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE ON A
SIX ZERO VOTE WE HAVE ONE LAST
ONE ITEM NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS
AB. THIRTY THREE TWELVE. THE
THIRTY THREE TWELVE IS TO PAY
IN TO THE FLOOR. MICHIGAN OKAY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
UNDER HERTZBERG BY FOR OUR-
SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO. SEVEN
ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE LAYS IN
GERMAN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. PLEASE KEEP YOUR
COUNTERS OPEN FOR A POTENTIAL
HEARING ON MONDAY MORNING FOR
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WE ARE NOW
ADJOURNED.